als und verteidigungspolitik und
deswegen natürlich an diesem morgen ganz
besonders gefragt frau broker wenn sie
entscheiden könnten ganz nach eigenen
vorstellungen völlig frei von äußeren
einflüssen welche entscheidungen würden
sie heute treffen die entscheidung die
wir auch getroffen haben in der
bundesregierung nämlich die ukraine mit
all dem was nur irgendwie möglich ist
jetzt in diesen schwierigen stunden
unter diesen brutalen angriffs krieg mit
den leidenden menschen zu unterstützen
und dieses per tasten sanktionen zu
verhängen die es je gab und auch die
lieferung von waffen zu genehmigen wie
einig sind sie sich da in ihrer partei
insgesamt oder waren sie recht aus der
fraktionssitzung es gab wirklich
einhellige unterstützung für diesen kurs
es wird ja auch gleich eine gemeinsame
entschließung des bundestages geben von
den koalitionsfraktionen aber auch
gemeinsam mit der opposition und ich bin
wirklich sehr dankbar dass es gelingt an
diesem schwierigen tag auch ein solches
starkes zeichen der einigkeit aus dem
deutschen parlament der solidarität mit
der ukraine und der der wirklich größten
verurteilung dieses brutalen
angriffskrieges auszusenden mit der
gesamten opposition oder mit großen
teilen der opposition müssen müssen wir
müssen müssen wir mal beobachten deren
organischen ob müssen wir beobachten im
laufe der sitzung die um 11 uhr beginnt
gerade folie ihre frühere
parteivorsitzende und chöre
verteidigungsministerin hat dieser tage
getwittert ich bin so wütend auf uns
weil wir historisch versagt haben wir
haben nach georgien krim und don was
nichts vorbereitet was putin wirklich
abgeschreckt hätte wie wütend sind sie
klar den mut kammer die wut kann man
verstehen dass das schon richtig wir
hätten mehr machen können und müssen das
ging nicht wieso uns nicht nur die
politischen mehrheiten dafür waren nicht
da wir haben auch immer wieder in der
letzten koalition versucht die spd zu
überzeugen mehr zu machen da gab es
widerstand wir haben die kanzlerin
gestellt die kanzlerin gestellt die
kanzlerin hat es auch unterstützt wir
haben immer wieder sagt wales gilt die
berühmten zwei prozent es muss mehr
ausgegeben werden dafür es war schwer
durchzusetzen aber wir sind jetzt an
einem verschärfen wir sind an einem
neuen punkt wir unterstützen gerne das
was die
koalition jetzt macht weil in der
situation nicht nur die internationale
gemeinschaft sondern auch der bundestag
im demokratischen spektrum zusammen
stehen muss und wir hören ja auch aus
der wirklich glaubwürdige zusagen für
die bundeswehr für die zukunft und da
müssen wir gemeinsam anpacken ich glaube
das ist auch eine gemeinsame aufgabe
jetzt einfach die verteidigungsfähigkeit
deutschlands zu verbessern das ist
wichtig das ist essentiell lebenswichtig
im engeren sinne sogar für uns und ich
denke da gibt es auch gemeinsamkeiten
ich möchte diese wut überwinden durch
produktivität in die zukunft ich muss
sie sind einen punkt natürlich trotzdem
sagen auch die bundeskanzlerin hat nur
zwei sehr unterstützt also werden wir
dann auch nicht vergessen also
das will dass wir niemand bestreiten das
hat wirtschaftsminister gabriel sehr
nach zwischenwelt weil sich so in die
richtung spd jetzt nach erschlug ich
meine das will ich schon noch sagen
erstens wirtschaftsminister gabriel kann
man auf spd-vorsitzender damals klammer
zu hat wesentlich nos mit zwei
protegiert die kanzlerin hat das
mitgemacht das muss man in der tat
einräumen und auch in der tat haben wir
natürlich die koalitionsfrage über den
verteidigungshaushalt nicht gestellt das
kann man im nachhinein bedauern aber
maximalen druck haben wir schon immer
gemacht also die bundeswehr ist wichtig
guck mal nach vorne frau brücke wie
bewerten sie denn die entscheidungen die
jetzt getroffen worden sind und was
erwarten sie von den oder was erhoffen
sie zumindest von denen dass sie
wirklich was bewirken dass russland und
wladimir putin die angriffe auf die
ukraine einstellen in absehbarer zeit
wir müssen jetzt wirklich alles dafür
tun um einzuwirken darauf dass diese
brutale gewalt aufhört und dass die
menschen in der ukraine sich selbst
verteidigen uns selbst schützen können
und natürlich wirken die sanktionen
nicht von heute auf morgen aber sie sind
sehr hart sie werden auch die russische
wirtschaft in aller härte treffen über
die frage
technologietransfer zugang zu
technologien bis hin zu der abkoppelung
von banken und natürlich ist die
hoffnung dass es auch gelingt ein
starkes zeichen der weltgemeinschaft aus
zusatz auszusenden angesichts der
beratung in den vereinten nationen das
ist wirklich der bruch des völkerrechts
wenn wir berichte waren über den einsatz
von streumunition ist es auch der bruch
des humanitären völkerrechts und die
kann man auch als weltgemeinschaft nicht
einfach zuschauen deshalb ist es richtig
hier eine sehr breite allianz der
entschiedenheit und der entschlossenheit
weltweit zu schmieden warum herr
wadephul helfen die waffenlieferungen
jetzt mitte der woche hatte sie noch
gesagt ich glaube sogar bei uns jetzt
kommt eigentlich zu spät man hätte für
sehr viel früher die waffenlieferungen
waffen liefern müssen an die ukraine
wenn ich es richtig in erinnerung habe
na ja wir haben dafür früher plädiert
das zu machen haben vor zwei wochen
herne debatte im deutschen bundestag
gehabt wo die unionsfraktion schon dafür
plädiert hat waffenlieferungen
aufzunehmen damals gab es noch
widerstand jetzt geschieht es ist nie zu
spät es gibt ja erstaunlichen widerstand
der ukrainischen armee und wenn wir dazu
einen beitrag leisten können dann sind
wir glaube ich politisch moralisch
verpflichtet das zu machen was sind ihre
erwartungen dass das alles ob das
aufgeht dieselbe frage dich jemand
freiburger auch gestellt hat es gibt ja
eine solidarisierung mit der ukraine die
die überwältigend ist und zwar nicht nur
in der westlichen welt da auch überall
demonstration sondern sogar innerhalb
russlands innerhalb auch vieler
nachbarstaaten viele dort merken da wird
ein bruder volk angegriffen ohne
wichtigen grund sogar noch mit einer
perfiden begründung man müsste eine
entnazifizierung vorantreiben also ich
glaube die der schuss im wahrsten sinne
des wortes kann für putin auch nach
hinten losgehen
die bundeskanzler von bruder hat von
einer zeitenwende gesprochen in einer
erklärung gestern
ich habe vorhin in der moderation schon
mal gesagt das außen- sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik müssen im grunde
vom kopf auf die füße gestellt werden
bzw völlig neu ausgerichtet werden was
ist das dringlichste was in deutschland
passieren muss wir müssen auf jeden fall
sehr klar haben was hier gerade passiert
ein brutaler angriffskrieg auf unserem
kontinent wir müssen die maßnahmen zum
schutz des bündnisgebietes und so auch
unserer nato partnerinnen und partner
verstärken auch dazu ist ja eine reihe
sind ja eine reihe von
maßnahmen auf den weg gebracht worden
und natürlich müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass sicherheit uns mehr wert ist und
zwar sicherheit in all ihren dimensionen
da geht es natürlich um den
verteidigungsetat aber auch um energie
souveränität um diplomatie um
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
humanitäre hilfe wenn wir natürlich auch
das sehen was gerade an der grenze
passiert aber im vordergrund erwartet
scheint jetzt zu stehen die bundeswehr
völlig neu aufzustellen als das wie es
in den vergangenen fast jahrzehnten oder
fangen zu sagen aber zumindest zwei
jahrzehnten der fall gewesen ist hat man
sich auf auslandseinsätze konzentriert
hat hier zurück wie der bündnis und
landesverteidigung in den vordergrund
was ist nötig und was ist schnell
realisierbar naja die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung haben wir schon 2014
wieder nach vorne gestellt und mit
trendwenden begonnen aber das muss
konsequent fortgeführt werden es ist
alles am ende gar nicht so schwer dieser
tage hat ein rüstungsunternehmen aus
deutschland 50 flugabwehr panzer der
ukraine zur verfügung gestellt und da
gesagt die könnten sie erwerben hier
könnte auch deutschland sofort kaufen
und dann hätten wir wieder eine
fähigkeit die uns jetzt fehlt ich sage
das nur als beispiel dafür
es gibt ganz einfache schnelle maßnahmen
damit deutschland wirklich wieder eine
bundeswehr hat die das erfüllen kann was
ihr kernauftrag ist nämlich deutschland
zu verteidigen und das bündnisgebiet zu
verteidigen ist eine
sicherheitspartnerschaft mit russland im
moment vorstellbar ist für mich aber
absehbare zeit nicht vorstellbar
wladimir putin hat nicht nur mit diesem
brutalen angriffs krieg die menschen in
der ukraine attackiert sondern hat
eigentlich wirklich zersprengt was über
jahrzehnte unser verständnis von
sicherheit in europa ausgemacht hat
nämlich über rüstungskontrolle über
abrüstung über diplomatie und gespräche
gemeinsame sicherheit für alle zu
zu organisieren und das ist wirklich
eine zäsur was heißt das für die nato
erwartet die nato hat eine neue
berechtigung willkommen viele staaten
wollen hinein das bekenntnis zur nato
ist in allen mitgliedstaaten sehr groß
sie ist nicht wie trainer gesagt hat
obsolet sondern wichtiger denn je
es fiel ging gestern einmalanmeldung rum
die der ukraine als beitrittskandidat
für die europäische union zu benennen
oder in augenschein zu nehmen oder sich
das ganze vorzustellen wie realistisch
ist eine solche idee und was würde sie
bedeuten für den innerhalb dieses
konflikts jetzt also jetzt unmittelbar
sozusagen stehen ganz andere fragen im
vordergrund aber natürlich all die
argumente mit denen man zu der frage
dato beitritt eu perspektive für die
ukraine bisher argumentiert hat auch die
stehen in frage auch hier hat sich die
lage vollkommen verändert und natürlich
gehört die ukraine zu unserem europa
dazu und braucht die solidarität aller
europäischen staaten jetzt mehr denn je
ihre sicht ja ich glaube das ist
vollkommen klar wir müssen zur ukraine
stehen aber jetzt die illusion zu wecken
dass die ukraine morgen in die nato
eintreten
auch in die eu beides erfordert
voraussetzungen die wir jetzt nicht
sofort erhöhen kann ich glaube es gibt
andere möglichkeiten die ukraine zu
unterstützen und dafür zu sorgen dass
sie stabil ist die eu ist immer darauf
ausgerichtet auch die staaten
aufzunehmen die zu ihr kommen wollen ich
glaube das wichtigste signal wäre jetzt
zum beispiel auf dem westlichen balkan
voran zu kommen da gibt es etliche
staaten die zu uns kommen wollen das
kann man schnell das kann man zügig
machen wir sind das merken wir jetzt in
einem wettstreit mit russland übrigens
auch mit china und der westen muss einen
zahn zulegen die bundesregierung der
bundeskanzler hat lange gezögert so
heißt es immer was beispielsweise den
das einbeziehen von swift in die
sanktionsliste
angeht nun hat man sich dafür
entschieden
wird das erreichen oder denken sie es
müssen noch sehr viel härtere sanktionen
folgen in absehbarer zeit es wird
wirklich alles geprüft was möglich ist
natürlich sind emotionale tweets immer
schnell ab aber die bundesregierung muss
dafür sorge tragen dass solche
sanktionen wirklich auch wirken dass sie
zielgenau diejenigen treffen die auch
dadurch bestraft werden sollen dass sie
rechtssicher sind und dass wir die
kollateralschäden beherrschen und diese
maßnahmen auch durchhalten könne ich
glaube es wird eine kontinuierliche
debatte geben was die nächsten maßnahmen
sein werden ihr vorsitzender merz hat
vor nicht allzu langer zeit noch von der
atombombe in anführungszeichen
gesprochen wird bedeuten würde auch das
war ja bedenken dass es die falschen
trifft auch seitens der bundesregierung
und des kanzlers jetzt die alternativlos
ja wir müssen das jetzt machen das wird
uns auch treffen darauf hat friedrich
merz hingewiesen dass muss man sehen
aber ich meine wenn wir sehen was die
ukraine in kauf nimmt dann sind das
marginale schäden die wir hier zu
gewärtigen haben wir müssen jetzt
wirklich für die freiheit und für den
frieden wirklich alles in die waagschale
werfen und dazu gehört trifft in jedem
fall dazu da relativieren sich dann
manche dinge und nichtsdestotrotz können
wir die die auswirkung von all dem was
jetzt im moment angestoßen wird und in
die bahn gebracht wird natürlich
überhaupt nicht absehen er war früher
vielen dank dass sie heute morgen bei
uns gewesen sind auch in freiburger
vielen dank sie dürfen jetzt in aller
ruhe rein gehen den sitzungen hat noch
nicht angefangen tut es aber gleich
deswegen dürfen sie sofort losgehen
vielen dank ihnen dass sie heute morgen
hier gewesen sind und wir schauen schon
mal in den plenarsaal der ausgesprochen
gut gefüllt ist wir sehen und die
bundestagspräsidentin eröffnet die
sitzung mit einer eigenen ansprache zum
thema und zur situation
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
auf der ehrentribüne begrüße ich
zunächst herrn bundespräsident gauck ich
freue mich dass sie heute anwesend sind
wir alle stehen unter dem eindruck
dramatischer ereignisse
was der westen mit vereinten kräften zu
verhindern versucht hat ist doch
eingetreten
wir haben krieg in europa
russlands präsident putin hat der
ukraine angegriffen die souveränität des
landes brutal verletzt den menschen in
der ukraine das recht auf
selbstbestimmung
abgesprochen
dieser überfall ist ein klarer bruch des
völkerrechts und ein angriff auf die
prinzipien der freiheitlichen welt
prinzipien die für deutschland und für
alle demokraten weltweit und
verhandelbar sind
auf der ehrentribüne begrüße ich den
botschafter der ukraine doktor andrej
melik
exzellenz in gedanken sind wir bei ihren
landsleuten die in diesen tagen die
freiheit und die demokratie verteidigen
am freitagabend habe ich in einem
telefonat mit meinem amtskollegen
russland stefan tschök allen mitgliedern
des ukrainischen parlaments und allen
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer unsere hilfe
und unterstützung angeboten
der deutsche bundestag und die menschen
in unserem land stehen fest an ihrer
seite
an der seite der freien und
demokratischen
ukraine
der deutsche bundestag kommt heute an
einem sonntag zu einer sondersitzung
zusammen in dieser historischen
ausnahmesituation
ist es auch ein wichtiges signal der
solidarität unseres gesamten hauses
der bundeskanzler wird gleich eine
regierungserklärung abgeben auf sein
verlangen gemäß artikel
39 absatz 3 des grundgesetzes in
verbindung mit § 21 absatz 2 unserer
geschäftsordnung habe ich die heutige
sondersitzung
einberufen
damit komme ich jetzt auch zu
tagesordnungspunkt 1 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch den
bundeskanzler zur aktuellen lage hierzu
liegen mehrere entschließungsanträge vor
nach einer interfraktionellen
vereinbarungen sind für die ansprache im
anschluss an die regierungserklärung
150 minuten vorgesehen ich höre kein
widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung hat der
bundeskanzler herr olaf scholz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
der 24 februar 2022 markiert eine
zeitenwende in der geschichte unseres
kontinents mit dem überfall auf die
ukraine hat der russische präsident
putin kaltblütig ein angriffskrieg vom
zaun gebrochen aus einem einzigen grund
die freiheit der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer stellt sein eigenes
unterdrückungsregime in frage das ist
menschenverachtend es ist
völkerrechtswidrig dass es durch nichts
und niemanden zu rechtfertigen
die schrecklichen bilder aus kiew odessa
mario pohl zeigt die ganze
skrupellosigkeit putins die
himmelschreiende ungerechtigkeit
der schmerz der ukraine noch keiner sie
gehen uns allen sehr nahe
ich weiß genau
welche fragen sich die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesen tagen abends am
küchentisch
welche sorgen sie umtreiben
angesichts der furchtbaren nachrichten
aus dem krieg
viele von uns haben noch die erzählung
unserer eltern oder großeltern immer vom
krieg
und für die jüngeren ist es kaum fassbar
krieg in europa
viele von ihnen verleihen ihrem
entsetzen ausdruck überall im land hier
in berlin
wir erleben eine zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die welt
davor
im kern geht es um die frage ob macht
das recht brechen darf ob wir es putin
gestatten die uhren zurückzudrehen in
die zeit der großmächte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts oder ob wir die kraft
aufbringen kriegstreibern nikotin
grenzen zu setzen
das setzt eigene stärke voraus
wir wollen und wir werden unsere
freiheit unsere demokratie und unserem
wohlstand sichern und ich bin ihnen frau
präsidentin sehr dankbar dass sich die
vorstellungen der bundesregierung dazu
heute in dieser sondersitzung mit dem
teilen kann und auch den vorsitzenden
aller demokratischen fraktionen dieses
hauses danke ich dafür dass sie diese
sitzung unterstützt haben
meine damen und herren mit dem überfall
auf die ukraine will putin nicht nur ein
unabhängiges land von der weltkarte
tilgen er zertrümmert die europäische
sicherheits ordnung wie sie seit der
schlussakte von helsinki
fast ein halbes jahrhundert bestand
hatte er stellt sich auch ins abseits
der gesamten internationalen
staatengemeinschaft
weltweit haben unsere botschaften in den
vergangenen tagen gemeinsam mit
frankreich dafür geworben die russische
aggression im sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen als das zu benennen
was sie ist ein infamer völkerrechts
bruch
und wenn man sich das ergebnis der
sicherheitsratssitzung in new york
anschaut durchaus mit erfolg die
beratung haben gezeigt wir stehen
keineswegs allein in unserem einsatz für
den frieden wir werden ihn fortsetzen
mit aller kraft dafür was sie dort
zustande gebracht hat bin ich aus
ministerium werbung sehr dankbar
[Applaus]
nur mit der notbremse seines vetos
konnte moskau immerhin ein ständiges
mitglied des sicherheitsrates die eigene
verurteilung verändern was für eine
schande
präsident putin redet dabei stets von
unteilbaren sicherheit
tatsächlich aber will er gerade den
kontinent mit waffengewalt in
altbekannte einflusssphären teilen
das hat folgen für die sicherheit in
europa
dauerhaft ist sicherheit in europa nicht
gegen russland möglich auf absehbare
zeit aber gefährte putin diese
sicherheit das muss klar ausgesprochen
werden
wir nehmen die herausforderung an vor
der die zeit uns gestellt hat nüchtern
und entschlossen
fünf handlungs aufträge liegen nun vor
uns
erstens wir müssen die ukraine in dieser
verzweifelten lage unterstützen das
haben wir auch in den vergangenen wochen
monaten und jahren in großem umfang
getan aber mit dem überfall auf die
ukraine sind wir in einer neuen zeit in
kiew
odessa und mario pohl verteidigen die
menschen nicht nur ihre heimat sie
kämpfen für freiheit und ihre demokratie
für werte die mit ihnen teilen
als demokratinnen und demokraten als
europäerinnen und europäer stehen wir an
ihrer seite auf der richtigen seite der
geschichte
am donnerstag hat präsident putin mit
seinem überfall auf die ukraine eine
neue realität geschaffen
diese neue realität erfordert eine klare
antwort wir haben sie gegeben wie sie
wissen haben wir gestern entschieden
dass deutschland der ukraine waffen zur
verteidigung des landes liefern wird
auf gutes aggression konnte es keine
andere antwort geben
meine damen und herren unser zweiter
handlungsauftrag ist putin von seinem
kriegsbuch kurs abzubringen der krieg
ist eine katastrophe für die ukraine
aber der krieg wird sich auch als
katastrophe für russland erweisen
gemeinsam mit den eu und staats und
regierungschefs haben wir ein
sanktionspaket von bisher unbekannten
ausmaß verabschiedet wir schneiden
russische bank und staatsunternehmen von
der finanzierung ab wir verhindern den
export von zukunfts technologie nach
russland
wir nehmen die oligarchen und ihre
geldanlagen in der eu ins visier hinzu
kommt die strafmaßnahmen gegen putin und
personen in seinem direkten umfeld und
einschränkungen bei der visavergabe für
russische offizielle
und wir schließen wichtige russische
banken von banken kommunikationsnetz
swift aus darauf haben wir uns gestern
mit dem staats und regierungschefs
[Musik]
machen wir uns nichts vor
putin wird seinen kurs nicht über nacht
ändern
doch schon sehr bald wird die russische
führung spüren welch hohen preis sie
bezahlt allein in der letzten woche
haben russische börsenwert um über 30
prozent nachgegeben das zeigt unsere
sanktionen wirken und wir behalten uns
weitere sanktionen vor ohne irgendwelche
denkverbote
unsere richtung bleibt die frage was
trifft die verantwortlichen am härtesten
die um die es geht und nicht das
russische volk
und putin nicht das russische volk hat
sich für den krieg entschieden
deshalb gehört es deutlich ausgesprochen
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
die differenzierung ist mir wichtig
denn die aussöhnung zwischen deutschen
und russen nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
ist und bleibt ein wichtiges kapitel
unserer gemeinsamen geschichte
und ich weiß wie schwierig zu ertragen
die derzeitige situation gerade für die
vielen bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes ist die in der ukraine oder in
russland geboren sind
darum werden wir nicht zulassen dass
dieser konflikt zwischen putin und der
freien welt zum aufreißen alter wunden
und zu neuen verwerfungen führt
und noch etwas sollten wir nicht
vergessen in vielen russischen städten
haben bürgerinnen und bürgern den
vergangenen tagen gegen kubins krieg
protestiert haben verhaftung und
bestrafung in kauf genommen das
erfordert große hilfe
deutschland steht heute an der seite der
ukraine ukraine unsere gedanken und
unser mitgefühl gelten heute den opfern
des russischen angriffskriegs
und genau so stehen der an der seite all
jene in russland die putins machtapparat
mutig die stirn bieten und seinen krieg
gegen die ukraine ablehnen wir wissen
sie sind fielen
ihnen allen sage ich geben sie nicht auf
ich bin ganz sicher
freiheit toleranz und menschenrechte
werden sich auch in russland durchsetzen
meine damen und herren die dritte große
herausforderung liegt darin zu
verhindern dass putins krieg auf andere
länder in europa übergreift das bedeutet
ohne wenn und aber stehen wir zu unserer
beistandspflicht in der nato
das habe ich auch unseren alliierten in
mittel und osteuropa gesagt die sich um
ihre sicherheit sorgen
präsident putin sollte unsere
entschlossenheit nicht unterschätzen
gemeinsam mit unseren alliierten jeden
quadratmeter des bündnisgebietes zu
verteidigen
wir meinen das sehr ernst mit der
aufnahme eines landes in die nato ist
unser wille als bündnispartner verbunden
dieses land zu verteidigen und zwar so
wie uns selbst
die bundeswehr hat ihre unterstützung
für die östlichen bündnispartner bereits
ausgeweitet und wird das weiter tun für
dieses wichtige signal danke ich dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium in
litauen wo wir den einsatz verband der
nato führen haben wir unsere truppe
aufgestockt
unseren einsatz beim r police in
rumänien haben wir verlängert und
ausgeweitet
wir wollen uns am aufbau einer neuen
nato einheit in der slowakei beteiligen
unsere marine hilft mit zusätzlichen
schiffen bei der sicherung von nord und
ostsee und im mittelmeer und wir sind
bereit uns mit luftabwehrraketen auch an
der verteidigung des luftraums unserer
alliierten in osteuropa zu beteiligen
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten haben in
den vergangenen tagen oft nur wenig zeit
gehabt sich auf diese einsätze
vorzubereiten
ich sage ihnen und sicher auch in ihrem
namen danke
danke und für ihren wichtigen dienst
gerade in diesen tagen
meine damen und herren angesichts der
zeitenwende die putins aggression
bedeutet lautet unser maßstab was für
die sicherung des friedens in europa
gebraucht wird das wird getan
deutschland wird dazu seinen
solidarischen beitrag leisten
dass heute klar und unmissverständlich
fest zu halten reicht aber nicht aus
denn dafür braucht die bundeswehr neue
starke fähigkeiten
und das ist mein viertes anliegen
und das ist mein viertes anliegen meine
damen und herren
putins historisierende abhandlung liest
wer seine öffentliche kriegserklärung an
die ukraine im fernsehen gesehen hat
oder wer wie ich kürzlich persönlich mit
ihm stundenlang gesprochen hat der kann
kein zweifel mehr haben
putin will an russisches imperium
richten
er will die verhältnisse in europa nach
seinen vorstellungen grundlegend neu
ordnen und dabei schreckt er nicht
zurück vor militärischer gewalt das
sehen wir heute in der ukraine
wir müssen uns daher fragen welche
fähigkeiten besitzt putins russland
und welche fähigkeiten brauchen wir um
dieser bedrohung zu begegnen heute und
in der zukunft
klar ist wir müssen deutlich mehr
investieren in die sicherheit unseres
landes um auf diese weise unsere
freiheit und unsere demokratie zu
schützen
das ist eine große nationale
kraftanstrengung
das ziel ist eine leistungsfähige
hochmoderne fortschrittliche bundeswehr
die uns zuverlässig schützt
ich habe bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vor einer woche
gesagt wir brauchen flugzeuge die
fliegen schiffe die in see stechen und
soldatinnen soldaten die für ihre
einsätze optimal ausgerüstete
darum geht es
und das ist ja wohl erreichbar für ein
land unserer größe und unserer bedeutung
in europa
aber machen wir uns nichts vor bessere
ausrüstungen modernes einsatzgerät mehr
personal das kostet viel geld
wir werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
und ich bin bundesfinanzminister lindner
sehr dankbar für seine unterstützung
dabei
der bundeshaushalt
2022 wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig
mit 100 milliarden euro ausstatten die
mittel werden der für notwendige
investitionen und rüstungsvorhaben
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und unsere
verteidigung investieren
und meine damen und herren ich richte
mich hier an alle fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages
lassen sie uns das sondervermögen im
grundgesetz absichern
eines will ich hinzufügen
wir streben dieses ziel nicht nur an
weil wir bei unseren freunden und
alliierten im wort stehen unsere
verteidigungsausgaben bis 2024 auf zwei
prozent unserer wirtschaftsleistung zu
steigern
wir tun dies auch für uns für unsere
eigene sicherheit
wohl wissend dass sich nicht alle
bedrohungen der zukunft mit den mitteln
der
bundeswehreinheiten lassen
deshalb brauchen wir eine starke
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
besser
deshalb werden wir unseren stark
technisch und gesellschaftlich zum
beispiel gegen cyberangriffe und des
informationskampagnen gegen angriffe auf
unsere kritische infrastruktur und
kommunikationswege
und wir werden technologisch auf der
höhe der zeit bleiben
darum ist es mir zum beispiel so wichtig
dass wir die nächste generation von
kampfflugzeugen und panzern gemeinsam
mit europäischen partnern und
insbesondere frankreich hier in europa
bauen diese projekte haben oberste
priorität für uns
bis die neuen flugzeuge einsatzbereit
sind werden wir den eurofighter
gemeinsam weiterentwickeln gut es auch
dass die verträge zur euro drohne in
dieser woche endlich unterzeichnet
werden konnten
auch die anschaffung der bewaffneten
heron drohne aus israel treiben wir
voran
und für die nukleare teilhabe werden wir
rechtzeitig einen modernen ersatz für
die veralteten tornado-jets geschaffen
der eurofighter soll zu electronic
warfare befähigt werden das
kampfflugzeug f 35 kommt als
trägerflugzeug in betracht
und schließlich meine damen und herren
werden wir mehr tun um unsere eine
sichere energieversorgung unseres landes
zu gewährleisten
eine wichtige maßnahme dazu hat die
bundesregierung bereits auf den weg
gebracht und wir werden um steuern um
steuern um unsere importabhängigkeit von
einzelnen energielieferanten zu
überwinden
ereignisse der letzten tage und wochen
haben uns doch gezeigt eine
verantwortungsvolle vorausschauende
energiepolitik ist nicht nur
entscheidend für unsere wirtschaft und
unser klima
sondern entscheidend auch für unsere
sicherheit
deshalb gilt je schneller wir den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien vorantreiben desto
besser
und wir sind auf dem richtigen weg wir
wollen als industrieland bis 2045 10 und
20 werden
mit diesem ziel vor augen werden wir
wichtige entscheidungen treffen müssen
etwa eine kohle und gas werse selber
aufzubauen wir haben beschlossen die
speichermenge an erdgas über so genannte
long term auction zum 2 milliarden
kubikmeter zu erhöhen zudem werden wir
rückgekoppelt mit der eu zusätzliches
erdgas auf den weltmärkten erwerbung
und schließlich haben wir die
entscheidung getroffen zwei
flüssiggasterminals lng terminals in
brunsbüttel und wilhelmshaven schnell zu
bauen
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich
möchte ich für seinen einsatz dabei ganz
ausdrücklich danken
dass das nun kurzfristig notwendig ist
lässt sich mit dem verbinden was
langfristig ohnehin gebraucht wird für
den erfolg der transformation ein lng
terminal in dem wir heute gas ankommen
lassen kann morgen auch grünen
wasserstoff aufnehmen
und natürlich behalten wir bei alldem
die hohen energiepreise im blick
wo dienst krieg hat sie zuletzt noch
weiter steigen lassen
deshalb haben wir in dieser woche ein
entlastungspaket vereinbart mit der
abschaffung der eeg umlage noch in
diesem jahr eine erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale um heizkostenzuschuss
für geringverdiener zuschüsse für
familien und steuerlichen entlastung die
bundesregierung wird das schnell auf den
weg bringen
unsere botschaft ist klar wir lassen die
bürgerinnen und bürger und die
unternehmen in dieser lage nicht allein
meine damen und herren die zeitenwende
trifft nicht nur unser land sie trifft
ganz europa und auch darin stecken
herausforderung und chance zugleich
die herausforderung besteht darin die
souveränität der europäischen union
nachhaltig und dauerhaft zu stärken die
chance liegt darin dass wir die
geschlossenheit waren die wir in den
letzten tagen unter beweis stellt haben
stichwort sanktionspaket
für deutschland und für alle anderen
mitgliedsländer der eu heißt das nicht
bloß zu fragen was man für das eigene
land in brüssel herausholen kann sondern
zu fragen was ist das beste was ist die
beste entscheidung für die union
[Applaus]
europa ist unser handlungsrahmen nur
wenn wir das begreifen werden wir vor
den herausforderungen unserer zeit
bestehen
und damit bin ich beim fünften und
letzten punkt
putins krieg bedeutet eine zäsur auch
für unsere außenpolitik
so viel diplomatie wie möglich ohne naiv
zu sein dieser anspruch bleibt
nicht naiv zu sein das bedeutet aber
auch kein reden um des redens linz für
echten dialog braucht es die
bereitschaft dazu auf beiden seiten
daran mangelt ist auf seiten putins ganz
offensichtlich und das nicht erst in den
letzten tagen und wochen
das heißt das für die zukunft
wir werden uns gespräch mit russland
nicht verweigern auch in dieser extremen
lage ist es die aufgabe der diplomatie
gesprächskanäle offen zu halten
alles andere halte ich für
unverantwortlich
meine damen und herren wir wissen wofür
wir einstehen auch angesichts unserer
eigenen geschichte wir stehen ein für
den frieden in europa
wir werden uns nie abfinden mit gewalt
als mittel der politik wir werden uns
immer stark machen wird es die
friedliche lösung von konflikten und wir
werden nicht ruhen bis der frieden in
europa gesichert ist
und dabei stehen wir nicht allein
sondern zusammen mit unseren freunden
und partnern in europa und weltweit
unsere größte stärke sind unsere
bündnisse und allianzen ihnen verdanken
wir das große glück dass unser land seit
über 30 jahren genießt in einem
vereinten land zu leben in wohlstand und
frieden mit unseren nachbarn
wenn wir wollen dass diese letzten 30
jahre keine historische ausnahme bleiben
dann müssen wir alles tun für den
zusammenhalt der europäischen union für
die stärke der nato für noch engere
beziehungen zu unseren freunden partnern
und gleichgesinnten weltweit ich bin
voller zuversicht dass uns das gelingt
denn selten waren wir und unsere partner
so entschlossen und so geschlossen
und in diesen tagen wir wissen um die
stärke freier demokratie wir wissen was
von einem breiten gesellschaftlichen und
politischen konsens getragen wird das
hat bestand auch in dieser zeitenwende
und darüber hinaus
und deshalb danke ich ihnen und allen
fraktionen dieses hauses die den
russischen überfall auf die ukraine
entschieden als das verurteilt haben was
er ist ein durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
da angriff auf ein unabhängiges land auf
die friedensordnung in europa und in der
welt der heutige entschließungsantrag
bringt das klar zum ausdruck
ich danke allen die in diesen tagen
zeichen setzen gegen putins krieg und
die sich hier in berlin und anderswo zu
friedlichen kundgebung versammeln
und ich danke allen die in diesen zeiten
mit uns einstehen für ein freies und
offenes gerechtes und friedliches europa
wir werden es verteidigen
[Musik]
stehender applaus für bundeskanzler olaf
scholz nach einer rede die ziemlich
genau 29 minuten gedauert hat stehender
applaus auch den rhein aus den reihen
der unions fraktion wie sie jetzt hier
sehen dass die ampel ihm applaudiert was
sie auch während seiner rede wiederholt
auch länger getan hat ist
selbstverständlich aber das ist doch
jetzt ein deutliches zeichen ja ist es
vielleicht doch ein historischer tag den
wir heute erinnern wenn man sich das
anschaut was der bundeskanzler referiert
hat insbesondere was das sondervermögen
bundeswehr angeht über eine rasse die an
dass die zwei prozent am
bruttoinlandsprodukt in verteidigung
angeht das ganze soll im grundgesetz
abgesichert werden die sicherheits und
verteidigungs und außenpolitik
deutschlands wird neu aufgestellt
friedrich merz der oppositionsführer
frau präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser
vierundzwanzigster september 2022
wird uns allen als ein tag im gedächtnis
bleiben von dem wir später einmal sagen
werden
ich weiß noch genau wo ich war
als ich die erste nachricht vom krieg in
der ukraine gehört und die ersten bilder
davon gesehen haben
unsere ersten gedanken in diesen minuten
galten und sie gelten unverändert bis
heute dem ganzen volk der ukraine
wir trauern mit den familien um die
opfer
dieses bis heute und auch in diesen
stunden und den minuten in so großer
zahl auch unter der zivilbevölkerung
gibt und wir bewundern den mut
und den willen dieses volkes um so eine
freiheit zu kämpfen
hier sind zugleich beschämt und bedrückt
dass in diesem land und diesem volk
nicht schon haben früher helfen können
der größte bewunderung und unser größter
respekt gilt dem frei gewählten
staatspräsidenten der ukraine präsident
wolodimir selensky
diesen diesen mutigen mann der aus einer
jüdischen familie stammt als
drogenabhängig und als nazi zu
diffamieren wie ist der russische
präsident in dieser woche getan hat
zeigt ein ausmaß an niedertracht und
menschenverachtung wie wir es in den
letzten jahrzehnten auf diesem kontinent
nicht erlebt habe
also das ganze sie haben es so
ausgedrückt mit diesem krieg geht eine
zeitepoche in europa zu ende eine zeit
von der wir erhofft und geglaubt haben
dass sie in frieden und in freiheit und
natürlich auch im wohlstand im ganzen
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
voranschreitet seit wenigen tagen sind
wir nun eines besseren belehrt
brutal und rücksichtslos
hat ein autoritäres system ein
angriffskrieg mitten in europa
mitten in europa denn dieser krieg für
den stadt zwischen den beiden
territorial größten ländern europas
russland ist ein europäisches land und
die ukraine ist ein europäisches land
der krieg findet statt weniger als zwei
flugstunden von diesem ort aus dem wir
uns heute morgen an einem sonntag
treffen herr bundeskanzler ich möchte
ihnen im namen der unionsfraktion und
der sie tragenden parteien cdu und csu
danken für ihre regierungserklärung
sie wissen
dass wir sehr darum bemüht sind mit
ihnen und den sie tragenden
koalitionsfraktionen einen gemeinsamen
weg in dieser zeit einer großen
herausforderung zu gehen wir haben in
den letzten tagen mit ihren
fraktionen um gemeinsame antworten
gerungen und wir geben sie wieder in
einem entschließungsantrag den wir heute
gemeinsam mit der spd den grünen und der
fdp
einbringen aber lassen sie mich das ganz
deutlich sagen dieser antrag ist nur das
gemeinsame minimum das wir heute hier
feststellen können wir haben und wir
behalten hoffentlich auch in der zukunft
eine klare auffassung zu diesem krieg
und seinem einzigen verantwortlichen der
verantwortliche mann heißt wladimir
putin
ausschließen aus diesem lupenreinen
demokraten der er nie war ist nun
endgültig und für alle welt sichtbar ein
kriegsverbrecher geworden
aber so einen krieg
gefehlt nicht einer alleine und er
entsteht auch nicht ohne ein politisches
umfeld
das verantwortliche system um ihn herum
ist ein geflecht von
geheimdienstoffizieren und erprobten
meistern der politischen propaganda wie
etwa sein außenminister lawrow ein
geflecht einer großen gruppe
hemmungsloser oligarchen die sich die
ressourcen dieses landes unter den nagel
gerissen haben und vor allem aus einem
repressiven staatsapparat der ohne jeden
anflug von rechtsstaatlichkeit beliebig
verhaftet vergiftet im lager steckt
familien zerstört und auch nicht davor
zurückschreckt mitten in den ländern
westeuropas
auftragsmorde zufolge
und damit an dieser stelle und meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen überhaupt kein missverständnis
entsteht die verantwortlichkeit liegt
allein dort und allein bei diesen
handelnden akteuren aber zu diesem
netzwerk zählen seit vielen jahren auch
mehr oder weniger gutgläubige
interessenvertreter in aller welt auch
und gerade hier in deutschland die sich
einmal als putin versteher gerieren das
andere mal als freunde russlands die bis
hin zu windigen
stiftungskonstruktionen nichts
unversucht lassen nichts unversucht
lassen
mit diesem system
mit diesem system geschäfte zu machen
und das ganze dann auch noch zu
versuchen der öffentlichkeit als
gemeinnützig zu vermitteln sie als
nützliche idioten ganz im sinne der
linien denkmuster zu bezeichnen ist dann
wohl noch die freundlichste umschreibung
dieses treibens auch und gerade hier im
wahrscheinlich
die bedrohung der ukraine durch einen
angriffskrieg ist aber nicht die einzige
bedrohung die wir in diesen tagen sehen
parallel zu den panzer rollen seit
jahren wenden von propaganda durch
europa die in zeiten der digitalisierung
und der sozialen netzwerke eine hohe
effizienz und damit einen großen schaden
erzeugen ein schaden der auch unsere
gesellschaftliche ordnung von ihnen
bedroht meine damen und herren zu dieser
propaganda
zu dieser propaganda zählt seit langem
die behauptung die nato sei der
eigentliche aggressor gegen das
friedliebende russland dies ist in der
tat großartige land müsse sich nun so
der allmächtige staatsapparat und sein
präsident gegen eine militärische
bedrohung zur wehr setzen dabei wissen
sie es alle besser herr putin auch sie
sind und waren von der nato
droht das wissen sie auch das wissen sie
auch
und damen und herren wenn sie von dieser
stelle aus sehen wer jetzt klatscht und
wer jetzt nicht klappt dann weiß ich
welche reden die im verlaufe des
heutigen vormittags hier noch zu hören
bekommen von ganz links und von ganz
rechts auf dieser seite
das wissen wir jetzt schon hier
anzuschauen wie sie dann hier gleich
sprechen werden aber meine damen und
herren die einzige die einzige bedrohung
dies für putin und seine nomenklatura
gibt die einzige bedrohung und die nimmt
er zu recht sehr ernst ist die bedrohung
seiner macht durch das eigene volk die
bedrohung durch freiheit und demokratie
auch in seiner nachbarschaft da ist die
bedrohung für dieses system und deshalb
und deshalb unterdrückt putin im eigenen
land jede opposition und deshalb macht
der gemeinsame sache mit alexander
lukaschenko der heute an diesem tag hier
während wir hier zusammen treten ein
sogenanntes referendum in belarus
abhalten lassen um die verfassung zu
ändern und ab dem morgigen tag in diesem
land auch atomwaffen stationieren zu
können meine damen und herren das ist
die neue realität in der wir in dieser
woche aufgebracht sind die
staatengemeinschaft des westens
die europäer die amerikaner viele andere
länder auf der welt reagieren auf diesen
bruch des völkerrechts und aller
verträge die wir mit russland bisher
gemacht haben mit konsequenz und härte
russland wird international isoliert das
land und seine repräsentanten werden
auch persönlich sanktioniert dazu gehört
damit dass hier kreist auch von meiner
seite richtigerweise swift das
internationale zahlungssystem mit dem
jetzt russland aus dem internationalen
zahlungsverkehr ausgeschlossen wird
warum ist ganz
herr bundeskanzler herzlichen dank dass
sie das heute morgen hier gesagt haben
dass sie in den letzten tagen darüber
intensive gespräche und verhandlungen
geführt haben einschließlich auch der
frage wie denn mit waffenlieferungen aus
mehreren europäischen ländern nach in
die ukraine jetzt umzugehen ist wichtig
ist das klare und unmissverständliche
signal vom heutigen tag genug ist genug
das spiel ist aus
lassen nämlich aber auch sehr deutlich
sagen gefragt sind jetzt nicht gute
reden am heutigen tag gefragt sind und
gute regierungserklärung ja liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen eine gute
regierung sind gefragt sind
stringenz und durchhaltevermögen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen denn dieses
durchhaltevermögen kann schon in wenigen
tagen auf harte proben gestellt werden
die sanktionen werden wirkung entfalten
nicht nur in russland sondern auch hier
bei uns
der krieg in der ukraine wird
konsequenzen fordern nicht nur in der
verteidigungspolitik sondern auch in
vielen anderen bereichen
und deshalb herr bundeskanzler bieten
wir ihnen heute an dieser stelle ihnen
und ihrer regierung umfassende konkrete
hilfe und unterstützung an wenn sie um
unterstützung und zustimmung für die
jetzt notwendigen umfassenden sanktionen
werben und sie tun es ja heute morgen
dann werden wir das unterstützen und
nicht im kleinen herummäkeln wenn sie
eine umfassende
wenn sie eine umfassende ertüchtigung
unserer streitkräfte wollen und wir
wollen sie ganz offensichtlich ab heute
mit ihnen dann werden wir auch gegen
widerstände diesen weg mit ihnen gehen
wenn sie es für notwendig erachten die
energiepolitik und die ihrer regierung
neu auszurichten wenn sie mit uns der
meinung sind dass wir jetzt endgültig
auf keine weiteren optionen der
energieerzeugung mehr verzichten dürfen
dann finden sie dabei unsere tatkräftige
unterstützung
und wenn sie
wenn sie es so wollen wie sie das heute
morgen hier vorschlagen dann können wir
auch darüber herr bundeskanzler reden
aber ein sondervermögen ist nicht ein
vermögen sondern ein sondervermögen sind
zunächst einmal neue schulden und wie
wir diese neuen schulden aufnehmen und
wie wir sie dann möglicherweise in
unserer verfassung verankern das geht
nicht allein mit einer
regierungserklärung am sonntagmorgen zu
machen da müssen wir dann in ruhe und im
detail sprechen
und lassen sie mich auch dies ganz klar
sagen lassen sie mich hier dies ganz
klar sagen das machen wir dann in allen
teilen gemeinsam nicht in der
arbeitsteilung dass wir mit ihnen für
die unangenehmen dinge den kopf
hinhalten und sie in ihrer koalition
dann unverändert weiter alle wohltaten
zu lasten der jungen generation
verteilen herr bundeskanzler das machen
wir dann nicht
aber
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das sind ja alles die mehr
oder weniger nahe liegenden
entscheidungen die wir jetzt kurzfristig
treffen müssen die eigentliche
herausforderung ist doch eine ganz
andere und sie liegt viel tiefer in
wahrheit stehen wir spätestens mit
dieser woche vor einem scherbenhaufen
der deutschen und europäischen außen-
und sicherheitspolitik der letzten jahre
und jahrzehnte
einige der einige der vermeintlichen
gewissheiten
einige der vermeintlichen gewissheiten
der letzten jahre gehören nun endgültig
der vergangenheit anderen wir sind nicht
mehr nur von freunden umgeben auch wir
werden durch einen aggressiven start in
unserer direkten nachbarschaft
bedroht einseitige abrüstung führt nicht
zu mehr sondern zu weniger sicherheit
oder hatten ein thema oder hat hier im
haus irgend jemand vergessen dass die
ukraine 1994 alle ihre atomwaffen
abgegeben hat und im gegenzug dazu von
russland umfassende und dauerhafte
garantien der territorialen integrität
erhalten hat man damit hat dass
irgendjemand von ihnen hier vergessen
und lassen sie mich das so sagen
lichterketten friedensgebete
ostermärsche sind eine schöne sache auch
wir haben heute morgen mit einer reihe
von abgeordneten aus dem deutschen
bundestag
auch wir haben heute morgen
auch wir haben heute morgen mit einer
gruppe von abgeordneten aus dem
deutschen bundestag und einigen
fraktionen um den frieden in der welt
gebetet und um das ende dieses krieges
gebetet aber meine damen und herren mit
moral allein wird die welt um uns drum
herum nicht friedlich schon gar nicht
mit der angeblich besseren moral die
immer wieder auch in deutschland
vorgetragen wird
der ukraine der ukraine jedenfalls haben
gute worte nichts genutzt auch nicht die
verpackte mitgliedschaft in der nato
meine damen und herren und schließlich
auch deutschland muss endlich bereit
sein in dieser welt seine interessen zu
definieren und vor allem bereit seien
vor allem bereit sein diese interessen
auch durchzusetzen
dazu zählt nicht nur aber auch die
fähigkeit das eigene territorium und die
eigene bevölkerung wirksam gegen jedwede
form der gewalt und der nötigung zu
schützen und zu verteidigen
die bundeswehr ist bereits gefragt die
bundeswehr ist dazu soweit sie gefragt
ist heute am tag jedenfalls nicht in der
lage
das sind
das sind also wenn da reagiere ich nicht
aber hier reagiere ich schon wenn sie
das zu einem thema der parteipolitischen
auseinandersetzung machen
was wir was wir waren damen und herren
wir
sind in diesem haus und ich war schon
ziemlich früh dabei wir sind in diesem
haus aller miteinander verantwortlich
dafür dass die bundeswehr in dem zustand
ist in dem sie heute ist wir haben uns
bemüht wir haben uns bemüht das zu
verbessern vieles ist an ihnen
gescheitert wenn wir heute einen neuen
weg nach vorn gehen dann gehen wir
gemeinsam aber nur dann wenn wir ihn
jetzt wirklich gemeinsam nach vorn geht
und nicht wenn sie hier parteipolitisch
zurückblicken da sind
das sind alles ja das sind alles
annahmen
das sind alles annahmen und politische
einschätzungen die sie hier im hause
teilen mögen oder auch nicht aber die
eigentliche
führungsaufgabe kommt in diesem
historischen augenblick so oder so auf
sie zu herr bundeskanzler lassen nämlich
deswegen abschließend lassen sie mich
deswegen abschließend aus einer großen
deutschen tageszeitung zitieren dies vor
einigen tagen aus meiner sicht sehr
präzise auf den punkt gebracht hat der
autor schreibt am woche am ende einer
sehr ernüchternden analyse wie folgt die
eigentliche rechnung aber wird in
deutschland selbst fällig wo diesen
krisen dichte auf eine weitgehend
unvorbereitete bevölkerung trifft der
schlicht das handwerkszeug fehlt um mit
erpressung nötigung militärische
bedrohung auf das politische system
umzugehen
unsicherheit so schreibt er weiter
entsteht in der regel durch einen
aggressor aber gefährlich wird sie erst
durch schwäche ende des zitats das
notwendige handwerkszeug herr
bundeskanzler
diese schwäche in unserem land zu
beseitigen
dieses notwendige handwerkszeug ist seit
dieser woche die historische aufgabe
ihrer kanzlerschaft herzlichen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
friedrich merz partei und
fraktionsvorsitzender der union hat gut
20 minuten geredet hatte einen kleinen
versprecher zu beginn als er vom 24
september statt vom 24 februar sprach
und hat hier nach zwei strategien im
grunde angeboten einerseits die
ausgestreckte hand was kooperation mit
der ampel koalition angeht mit vielen
zielen ist man sich einig sagte
friedrich merz auf der anderen seite
aber eine klare abgrenzung
beispielsweise was die finanzierung
angeht das wird allerdings auch in der
koalition eine ausgesprochen lebhafte
debatte noch zur folge haben dass
bundeskanzler scholz hier in seiner rede
in seiner regierungserklärung gesagt hat
zu einem sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr und allen weiteren denen die
da auf den gta und den haushalt zu
kommen die bundes außenministerin
annalena baerbock ist die nächste
rednerin
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger die bilder aus der ukraine
sind kaum zu ertragen
tausende fliehen wahrscheinlich jeder
hier im saal hat eine nachricht bekommen
von freunden bekannten von kolleginnen
und kollegen mit dem man so wie ich
letzte woche noch gemeinsam in kiew
mittag gegessen hat die jetzt sagen
'bitte rettet uns eltern mit kleinen
kindern verbringen in u-bahn-schächten
ihre nächte um schutz vor bomben und
raketen zu suchen das könnten wir in
diesem bahn schächten sein dass könnten
unsere kinder sein was wir gerade mitten
in europa passiert war jemand aus meiner
generation bisher unvorstellbar es ist
der moment in dem der angriffskrieg nach
europa zurück gekommen ist
unsere welt ist nach diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg von
putin jetzt eine andere
botschaft wenig ich begrüße sie hier im
st alten stellvertretend für die über 40
millionen mutigen ukrainerinnen und
ukraine
[Applaus]
ich möchte ihnen hier aus ganzem herzen
sagen das unsägliche leid der männer
frauen und kinder trifft uns ins mark
wir sind fassungslos angesichts dessen
was der ukraine was den menschen in der
ukraine erneut angetan wird aber wir
sind nicht ohnmächtig wir lassen sie in
dieser rücksichtslosen aggression auf
gelangt nicht alleine
dieser krieg ist kein krieg der menschen
in russland
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
dieser krieg ist ein angriff auf unseren
frieden in europa dieser krieg ist ein
angriff auf unsere freiheit dieser krieg
ist ein angriff auf das internationale
völkerrecht dieser krieg ist ein angriff
auf all die werte einer regelbasierten
internationalen ordnung und dieser krieg
ist ein angriff auf das menschliche
friedliche miteinander
und es ist ein krieg der es nötig macht
dass wir die grundfesten unseres
außenpolitischen handelns 19 vor wenigen
wochen noch habe ich hier in diesem saal
zum thema waffenlieferungen gesagt dass
man seine außenpolitische
180 grad wendung im richtigen moment und
bei vollem bewusstsein treffen muss
jetzt ist so traurig es ist der moment
dafür wir haben es bis zuletzt bis zur
letzten minute mit diplomatie versucht
der kreml hat uns hingehalten belogen
und sich all dem verweigert wofür wir
bisher als europäerinnen und europäer
eingestanden haben putin wollte diesen
krieg whatever it takes russland hat die
ukraine rücksichtslos angegriffen und
die ukraine hat jedes land dieser welt
ein recht auf selbstverteidigung per
brief in der tat hat der verein
und wir die auf dem boden des
völkerrechts stehen stehen auch in der
pflicht diese charta der vereinten
nationen jetzt gemeinsam zu verteidigen
vielleicht ist es so
dass deutschland am heutigen tag eine
form besonderer und alleinstehender
zurückhaltung in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik hinter sich zuletzt
die regeln die wir uns dafür gegeben
haben dürfen uns nicht aus unserer
verantwortung nehmen wenn unsere welt
ein andere ist dann muss auch unsere
politik eine andere sein
ein land mit einer parlamentsarmee und
umfassender demokratischer kontrolle
darf und muss sich erlauben und das tun
wir mit dem heutigen tag in fragen von
krieg und frieden in voller
verantwortung zu entscheiden
wir werden bei waffenexporten und
einsetzen weiter aus tiefster
überzeugung zurückhaltend sein wir
werden uns aber in dieser historischen
stunde
angesichts des brutalen angriffs auf die
ukraine für eine unterstützung
entscheiden die neben unserem großen
wirtschaftlichen und humanitären
engagement die ukraine jetzt auch mit
lieferung von militärischen material und
waffen unterstützt
weil wir dürfen die ukraine nicht
wehrlos dem aggressor überlassen der tod
und verwüstung über dieses land bringt
und ich sage ihnen alle sehr wie auch
der bundeskanzler das ist die stärke
dieses hohen hauses das ist die stärke
unserer liberalen demokratie dass ihr
bei sachfragen streiten können erbittert
aber dass wir in dem moment wo es darum
geht unsere grundwerte zu verteidigen
alle
fraktionsübergreifend beieinander stehen
herzlichen dank
die bundesaußenministerium annalena
baerbock mit ihrer bilder an diesem
wir tun das weil unsere internationale
ordnung auf dem spiel steht wir tun dies
mit besonnenheit und aus verantwortung
um unseren frieden in europa und das ist
auch eine klare botschaft an ladung
jakutien das preisschild dieses krieges
gegen unschuldige menschen oder bruch
mit der charta der vereinten nationen
wird für das system putin und tragbar
seien
wir müssen und das hat der bundeskanzler
unterstrichen jetzt vieles gleichzeitig
tun wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
menschen in der ukraine schnell mit dem
nötigsten versorgt werden mit
medizinischen gütern mit sicheren
unterkünften
dafür haben wir unter anderen unseren
beitrag zum humanitären
hilfe für die ukraine um 5 millionen
aufgestockt wir stellen für das
internationale komitee des roten kreuzes
weitere hilfe in höhe von zehn millionen
euro kurzfristig bereit wir werden uns
mit allem was wir da haben gemeinsam
dafür einsetzen dass die menschen die
jetzt liegen alle alle in sicherheit
kommen und dafür haben wir
vorbereitungen getroffen und auch das
ist unsere stärke nicht nur in der
europäischen union sondern gemeinsam mit
unseren freunden in kanada in amerika
und an vielen vielen anderen orten in
der welt wir lassen die fliehenden
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht im
stich
und ja auch an dieser stelle müssen wir
bei geld reden und ich bitte um die
unterstützung im vorausschauenden
haushalt eben diese humanitäre hilfe
dann auch so auszustatten wie wir das
für den schutz der menschen brauchen
weitere elemente sind entscheidend
erstens sanktionen und die bittere
realität ist keine sanktionen kann
diesen bahn in diesem moment stoppen wir
hätten wenn wir ein sanktionsmittel
hätte dass alle stopp natürlich dieses
längst ergriffen aber was unsere
sanktionen leisten und das ist zentral
ist putin zu zeigen mittel und
langfristig wird dieser krieg ihr land
ruinieren putins perfides spiel ist auf
strecke angelegt deswegen müssen das auf
unsere sanktionen seien und deswegen
müssen wir so sicherstellen dass uns
nicht nach drei monaten die puste
ausgeht sondern diese sanktionen müssen
das system putin im kern treffen
deswegen
deswegen gehen sie hand in hand
wirtschaftlich finanziell und
individuell deswegen listen wir herrn
putin selbst und den außenminister lauf
wurf sie tragen verantwortung für diesen
krieg und deswegen werden wir weitere
sanktionen auf den weg bringen mit blick
auf banken oligarchen und
familienangehörige und deswegen haben
wir es trifft und ich kann verstehen
dass da einige etwas nervös geworden
sind aber ich bitte in diesen zeiten um
vertrauen deswegen haben wir es wirft so
angelegt dass sie das system putin
treffen und nicht als um rang auf uns
zurück kommen und das gemeinsam mit der
internationalen verantwortung die sie
jetzt gemeinsam zeigen
wir unterstützen unsere bündnispartner
im namen der rat hof nato das hat der
bundeskanzler bereits deutlich gemacht
die nato ist der garant für unsere
sicherheit und freiheit dafür wurde sie
gegründet und daran hat sich nichts
verändert
und mein letzter punkt ja wir müssen
härte zeigen aber wir stehen hier führt
das internationale recht und tina zu
internationalen regeln ein deswegen
gehört in diesem moment der dialog immer
mit dazu nicht mit dem adresse sondern
mit der internationalen gemeinschaft das
muss jetzt unser absoluter fokus sein es
geht hier nicht nur um europa kein land
der welt kann akzeptieren dass seine
souveränität zur disposition steht wenn
sein stärkerer nachbar es will
dann hätte putin gewonnen deswegen
müssen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam mit allen
staaten die wie wir an die charta der
vereinten nationen glauben dieser
aggression entgegen stellen deswegen
appelliere ich auch hier an all unsere
partner weltweit hier aus diesem
geschichtsträchtigen hohen haus bekennen
sie nächste woche farbe in der
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen dass es unsere internationale
friedensordnung wir müssen sie jetzt
gemeinsam verteidigen
bei der wahl zwischen krieg und frieden
bei der wahl zwischen einem aggressor
und kindern auf der anderen seite die
sich in u bahn schächten verstecken da
kann niemand neutral sein danke dass wir
das heute hier gemeinsam deutlich machen
bundesministerin werbung und ich bitte
um entschuldigung für den vier staaten
mitten in ihrer rede dadurch dass vielen
dank etwas falsch gedeutet
annalena baerbock ups wie hier nochmal
die sanktionen begrünen mittel kommen
sollen hat auch weitere angekündigt hat
aber auch eine botschaft in die eigenen
reihen noch vermittelt sie sagt wir
werden bei waffenlieferungen
grundsätzlich zurückhaltend bleiben
diese jetzige situation dieser nebel auf
die ukraine hat eine andere dimension
und dessert wie deshalb erfordert sie
auch andere entscheidungen alles weitere
ko fraktionsvorsitzende der afg es die
nächste rednerin
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
russlands angriffskrieg auf ein
nachbarland ist ein rückruf in die raue
welt der realpolitik das ukrainische
volk zahlt den preis für den russischen
völker rechtsbruch für die illusion der
eigenen führung um für die falschen
versprechungen des westens
es war ein verhängnisvoller fehler die
ukraine mit den unerfüllbaren
versprechen einer mitgliedschaft in nato
und eu in eine aussichtslose
konfrontation und eine gefährliche
zerreißprobe zu locken klüger
klüger wäre es gewesen auf henry
kissinger zu hören der schon 2014
richtig festgestellt hat ich zitiere um
zu überleben und sich zu entwickeln darf
die ukraine niemandes vorposten sein
zitat ende das eine nato mitgliedschaft
der ukraine eine rote linie darstellt
deren überschreiten russland nicht
hinnehmen würde wie die vorangegangen
nato aus erweiterungsrunden liegt seit
fast zwei jahrzehnten klar auf dem tisch
unzählige gelegenheiten wurden seither
versäumt einen status gesicherter
neutralität für die ukraine auszuhandeln
der den sicherheitsinteressen aller
rechnungen getragen und der ukraine
ermöglicht hätte vom zankapfel zu einer
brücke zwischen ost und west zu werden
stattdessen haben die hardliner gefangen
in einer völlig überkommenen logik des
kalten krieges star an der
beitrittsperspektive für die ukraine
festgehalten und dabei überheblich
russland den großmacht status
abgesprochen das ist das historische
versagen des westens die kränkung
russlands es ändert nichts an der
verwerflichkeit des russischen einmarsch
aber das verständnis aller ursachen ist
voraussetzung für die suche nach
lösungen
deutschland hat in seinem gegenwärtigen
zustand nicht aufzubieten um den worten
auch taten folgen zu lassen
sanktionen die den eigenen bürgern am
ende mehr schaden zufügen als denen die
damit gemeint sind werden dem krieg in
der ukraine kein ende setzen können sie
sind letztendlich alibi und
sanktionspolitik sowie das anstrahlen
des brandenburger tores in den
ukrainischen nationalfarben die
gescheiterte energiewende
sehr geehrte damen und herren hat uns in
eine fatale einseitige abhängigkeit von
russischen erdgaslieferungen geführt die
kurzfristig wenn überhaupt nur zu
astronomischen kosten gelöst werden kann
wer erklärt wir seien bereit dafür auch
einen hohen wirtschaftlichen preis zu
zahlen muss auch sagen es ist die
bevölkerung devisen preis zu zahlen hat
es hat im übrigen auch gründe dass die
usa nicht daran denken auf ihre
beträchtlichen öl importe aus russland
zu verzichten
sicherheitspolitisch ist deutschland
ebenfalls ein leichtgewicht geworden die
bundeswehr steht blank da besteht sogar
der inspektor des heeres in selten
gewordener offenheit ein eine
heruntergewirtschaftete armee und eine
marginalisierte rüstungsindustrie das
ist das erbe von 16 jahren angela merkel
herr merz
wer soll uns noch ernst nehmen wenn wir
uns wirtschaftlich und militärisch das
rückgrat brechen und uns statt mit
realen problemen mit gender gaga und
ideologischen experimenten dort
beschäftigen das ist grober unfug
wir müssen den weckruf der realpolitik
hören wir brauchen energie politik die
den fokus auf unabhängigkeit und
versorgungssicherheit liegt der
schlüssel dazu sind weder noch mehr
windräder noch flüssiggas aus den usa
sondern der wiedereinstieg in die
friedliche nutzung der kernenergie wie
denn auch sonst
wir brauchen
eine bundeswehr die die fähigkeit zur
landesverteidigung zurückgewinnt das
erfordert nicht allein mehr geld sondern
vor allem eine strategische wende sehr
geehrte damen und herren und wir
brauchen geopolitische nüchternheit
stadt feministischer aussenpolitik
haltung
haltung und schöne worte sind kein
ersatz für realpolitik und noch nach
diesen krieg werden wir mit russland
immer noch auf einem kontinent leben die
herausforderung eine europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur zu schaffen die
das ost west blockdenken überwindet ist
nicht vom tisch aber sie ist schwieriger
geworden
deutschland kann und sollte hier eine
wichtige rolle als ehrlicher makler
spielen voraussetzung ist dass wir die
richtigen konsequenzen ziehen und
verlorenes vertrauen souveränität und
handlungsfreiheit wieder aufbauen und
uns bloß nicht unreflektiert in einen
krieg hineinziehen lassen sehr geehrte
damen und herren ich bedanke mich
alles weitere war das ko vorsitzende der
spd-fraktion und sie hat von der tribüne
gesprochen da sind all die abgeordneten
die keine auskunft geben wollen über
ihren impfstatus und also er nicht
gewusst hat sind und das wahlweise
können die aber auch keinen test ja und
in keinen negativen test vorzeigen mögen
christian lindner ist folglich unten am
pult und der bundesfinanzminister
spricht jetzt
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist krieg in europa
was geschichte wahr ist gegenwart
geworden
es ist kriegen europa der 24 februar
trend dass vorher vom nachher
es reicht nicht mehr
über freiheit und die werte des
grundgesetzes über internationale
zusammenarbeit und solidarität zu reden
jetzt ist die zeit die werte des
grundgesetzes
freiheit und internationale solidarität
zu leben
russland hat einen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine begonnen
das ist das ende aller hoffnung auf
frieden und es ist auch das ende aller
illusionen über putins russland in
dieser zeit der entscheidung ist
klarheit gefordert wo wir stehen wir
stehen in solidarität an der seite der
ukraine
was haben wir hier gerade gehört
was für ein bild der gründe warum es zu
diesen krieg gekommen ist
sagen wir es in aller klarheit
putin hat die ukraine angegriffen weil
sich ein souveräner staat
in freier selbstbestimmung
dafür entschieden hat seinen weg nach
westen zu gehen
die ukraine ist ein souveräner staat
und wird von ihrem recht gebrauch
gemacht über ihre zukunft zu entscheiden
und sie hat sich gegen autorität ismus
entschieden sie hat sich für demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit entschieden
dafür ist sie angegriffen worden
der angriff auf die ukraine ist deshalb
nicht nur der überfall auf einen
souveränen staat es ist ein angriff auf
eine werteordnung es ist ein angriff auf
uns alle
wir waren uns sind solidarisch mit der
ukraine gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
in der europäischen union und im kreise
der g 7 deutschland hat in der
vergangenheit erhebliche finanzielle
mittel bereitgestellt zur unterstützung
der ukraine und das werden wir
fortsetzen schon in dieser woche werden
wir im kreis der g 7 staaten beraten was
an zusätzlicher hilfe nötig ist wir sind
aber zugleich auch entschlossen
wir ziehen diejenigen mit den mitteln
des rechts zur rechenschaft
die verantwortung dafür tragen dass das
völkerrecht gebrochen wurde wir werden
russland isolieren
wirtschaftlich finanziell und politisch
hier treffen
wir treten russlands banken wir treffen
russlands oligarchen wir treffen
russlands wirtschaft diese aktionen wie
wir beschlossen haben diese sanktionen
sind auf dauer angelegt wir brauchen
einen langen atem
wir haben diesen langen atem
diese sanktionen werden negative
auswirkungen auch auf uns haben aber wir
sind bereit diese negativen auswirkungen
zu tragen denn sie sind der preis der
freiheit
die bundesregierung unternimmt alles um
maximalen druck auf putin auszuüben und
zugleich eine schwäche und unserer
position zu begrenzen
erstens wir haben
sorgfältig unter federführung des
kanzleramts an finanziellen sanktionen
gearbeitet die putin keinen vorwand
biete
notwendige rohstofflieferungen
auszusetzen die auf der anderen seite
aber erreichen dass es mit russland
wortwörtlich kein business as usual mehr
geben wird
und damit enden wir nicht die deutschen
und europäischen finanzbehörden wir
werden alles unternehmen um
geldströme und
vermögenswerte derjenigen die putin
unterstützen zu identifizieren und
einzufrieren
zweites
wir werden reserven bei gas und kohle
aufbauen um unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit auszubauen dafür
haben wir mittel im milliardenbereich
eingeplant
drittens die bedeutung der
energiesicherheit
erfährt eine neue priorität
unsere planungen der nächsten jahre
werden wir an die veränderte lage
anpassen müssen dabei werden wir nicht
setzen auf die antworten der
vergangenheit sondern im gegenteil den
weg in die zukunft
entschlossener fortsetzen erneuerbare
energien läuft nämlich nicht nur einen
beitrag
zur energiesicherheit und versorgung
erneuerbare energien lösen uns von
abhängigkeiten erneuerbare energien sind
deshalb frei heizenergie
wir setzen auch freiheits energie
viertens
die stabilität der öffentlichen finanzen
und die handlungsfähigkeit des staates
müssen erhalten bleiben
die schuldenbremse gilt
das vertrauen der internationalen
kapitalmärkte in deutschland begründet
eine unserer stärken
und fünftens die
anstrengungen die vor uns liegen sind
enorm die anstrengungen die vor uns
liegen erfordern wirtschaftliche stärke
und deshalb ist auch eine konsequenz aus
der veränderten geopolitischen lage dass
wir unsere eigene wirtschaftliche
substanz stärken und alles unterlassen
was diese wirtschaftliche stärke
reduziert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
[Applaus]
wir haben viele jahre eine
friedensdividende genutzt
bundeswehr wurde vernachlässigt
in diesen tagen wurde noch über eine
taxonomie gesprochen die investitionen
in
verteidigungsfähigkeit eingeschränkt
hätte
der krieg in der ukraine
weckt uns alle aus einem
selbstgerechten traum
die zeit der vernachlässigung der
bundeswehr muss enden
wir werden deshalb in der laufenden
finanzplanung und in jedem haushaltsjahr
die mittel für den verteidigungshaushalt
erhöhen
wir werden den laufenden betrieb der
bundeswehr
werden den laufenden betrieb der
bundeswehr aus den laufenden haushalten
unter achtung der schuldenbremse
finanzieren aber eine jahrelange
mindestens 15 jahre dauernde
vernachlässigung der bundeswehr
kann man nichts von jetzt auf gleich im
laufenden haushalts korrigieren und
deshalb
und deshalb müssen wir zu einem anderen
mittel greifen die bundeswehr zwar
tüchtig
notwendiges material um notwendige
technik anzuschaffen werden wir der
bundeskanzler hat es gesagt ein
sondervermögen einrichten
100 milliarden euro wollen wir dafür zur
verfügung stellen wir wollen dieses
sondervermögen im grundgesetz absichern
um deutlich zu machen dass die
verwendung nur und ausschließlich für
die stärkung unserer bündnisfähigkeit
gedacht ist dafür brauchen wir die
unterstützung der länder
dafür brauchen wir die unterstützung der
cdu csu friedrich merz wir werden nicht
danach fragen
wer die verantwortung für den zustand
der bundeswehr hat wir werden nicht mit
dem finger aufeinander zu zeigen
aber wir erwarten dass beim blick in die
zukunft und bei der schaffung einer
bundeswehr die wieder ihren
bündnisverpflichtungen gerecht werden
kann die opposition die bundesregierung
unterstützt
ja
ja 100 milliarden euro neben den
jährlichen haushalten das ist eine
enorme summe geld sprechen wir es offen
aus am geld allein hat es nicht
gemangelt sondern wir werden auch über
die strukturen der bundeswehr sprechen
müssen über ihren auftrag
über die möglichkeit mit den mitteln
auch tatsächlich äußere sicherheit zu
garantieren
für diese debatte sind wir offen diese
debatte werden wir führen aber die
investitionen in die bundeswehr über
friedrich merz die sollten sie nicht
führen mit der warnung von neuen
schulden das sind in wahrheit natürlich
kredite die wir aufnehmen in den
nächsten jahren aber in dieser welt lage
sind es zunächst und zumeist
investitionen in unsere freiheit
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
was sind das für mutige menschen in der
ukraine die für ihre freiheit kämpfen
die in ihrem land
unsere westlichen werte leben wollen
sie nehmen uns auch in eine
verantwortung sie nehmen uns in die
verantwortung dass auch wir hier unsere
werte ernst nehmen wir sind solidarisch
mit der ukraine
weil ein volk über seine zukunft frei
entscheiden soll aber wir sind auch
solidarisch mit der ukraine weil sie
eine inspiration für uns selbst ist ich
danke
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
sagt kredite sind investitionen in
unsere freiheit dafür bekommt er jetzt
gehen stehendem applaus aus seiner
fraktion und dann schauen wir mal wenn
die kamera weiter auf zieht ob auch aus
anderen reihen noch so ganz genau hat er
aber immer noch nicht gesagt wo das geld
die milliarden herkommen sollen
beispielsweise für das sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr wirtschaftliche
stärke alleine wird dazu nicht reichen
die nicht so rednerin ist die co
vorsitzende der linksfraktion an ihrer
mohammed ali
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen in den morgenstunden des 24
februar sind wir in einem europa
aufgewacht das nie wieder so sein wird
wie vorher wir teilen natürlich klar die
auffassung dass russland einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine führt wladimir putin hat den
verhandlungstisch mutwillig verlassen
und bringt auf skrupellose art und weise
ganz europa und die welt in die konkrete
gefahr eines krieges dieser angriff
krieg muss sofort beendet werden soll
daten müssen sofort zurückgezogen
sie wissen sie wissen dass wir als linke
häufig das verhalten der nato kritisiert
haben die sich mehrfach nicht an
völkerrecht gehalten hat aber um es
unmissverständlich zu sagen dieser
russische angriff ist durch nichts zu
relativieren
durch nichts zu rechtfertigen kollegen
und
in der ukraine schwer haben kinder
frauen und männer angstvoll drängen sich
menschen den u-bahnhöfen familie werden
auseinandergerissen wohngebäude werden
zerstört hunderttausende sind auf der
flucht vor allem frauen und kinder die
bilder die uns täglich erreichen sind
unfassbar schockiert bei vielen menschen
in ganz europa besonders bei den älteren
die die schrecken und das leid des
zweiten weltkrieges noch erlebt haben
wächst die angst
meine meine tante hilde aus heide sie
ist 95 jahre alt die rief vor ein paar
tagen an und sagte sie hat wieder angst
vor krieg auch das ist erschüttert
kollegen kollegen ich kann für mich
persönlich und meine partei und sicher
auch für viele hier im raum sprechen
wenn ich sage wir haben das nicht für
möglich gehalten diesen angriffs
russland auf die ukraine diesen
verbrecherischen abgehen haben wir wie
auch viele experten experten nicht
erwartet für meine partei die linke
freue mich in aller deutlichkeit ein
dass wir die absichten der russischen
regierung falsch eingeschätzt haben
das
das macht uns nachdenklich wir bewerten
die lage heute anders und sagen klar
putin ist hier der aggressor und muss
sofort aufgehalten werden seine
großmacht fantasien die dürfen nicht
realität
wir stehen geschlossen an der seite der
polnischen bevölkerung an der seite
derer die in der ukraine um ihr leben
fürchten müssen an der seite derer die
sie auf der flucht befinden bei uns und
warum sie in deutschland oder in
angrenzenden ländern schutz suchen die
sind hier bekommen wir müssen wir uns
gemeinsam mit den ländern der
europäischen union um diese menschen
kümmern für alle menschen jetzt von
krieg und terror aus leute fliehen
braucht es eine unbürokratische aufnahme
regelung und einen gesicherten
aufenthaltsstatus kolleginnen kollegen
heißt bewusst bekenntnis habe ich in
ihrer rede leider vermisst wir sind auch
solidarisch mit den mutigen menschen die
zur stunde in russland putin die stirn
bieten und für den frieden demonstrieren
sie werden karate würdest ihre folgen
von denen heute keiner weiß wie schwer
wiegen sie für die betroffenen sein
werden diese stimme des friedens in
russland gegen putin die müssen wir
stärken
kollegen überlegen wir stellen fest dass
wir in der bewertung dieses angriffs und
den demokratischen fraktionen in diesem
haus große einigkeit haben darum haben
wir in unserem antrag viele passagen
ihres antrags auch wörtlich übernommen
bei der frage was es jetzt allerdings zu
tun gilt sind wir in mehreren punkten
andere aufpassen denn was sich bei uns
bei aller nachdenklichkeit und
neubewertung der lage nicht geändert hat
ist unsere tiefe überzeugung dass
abrüstung und diplomatie der weg zum
frieden sind darum können wir niemals
verstehen dass waffen in krisengebiete
geliefert werden und aufgerüstet wird er
schleust sie haben in ihrer rede gesagt
dass es ein sondervermögen geben soll
100 milliarden euro das grundgesetz soll
dafür geändert werden
und ich muss es einfach in der
deutlichkeit sagen dieses hochrüsten
diese militarisierung die können und
werden wir als linke nicht mit
über zivile hilfe habe ich von ihrer
rede leider auch nichts gehört herr
scholz frau weber hat es gesagt
selbstverständlich unterstützt
unterstützen wir das im haushalt dieser
posten zur verfügung gestellt wird was
denn sonst aber auf der einen seite und
ein sondervermögen auf der anderen seite
geht es um einen haushaltsposten
kolleginnen kollegen da ist etwas in
schieflage ich möchte man sagen
die geschichte lehrt uns das wettrüsten
keine sicherheit schafft wir müssen bei
dem was wir jetzt tun nicht nur das
heute im blick haben sondern auch dass
morgen und das übermorgen und die
notwendigkeit insbesondere zur atomaren
abrüstung auf allen seiten die ist doch
heute dringlicher und deutlicher denn je
zum thema sanktionen ist überhaupt kein
zweifel daran dass weder putin noch
seine regierung noch die mächtige
oligarchen die hinter dem angriffskrieg
stehen irgendeine schonung verdient
haben genauso wie die russische
rüstungsindustrie
anders sieht es
anders sieht es bei der russischen
bevölkerung aus das kann man nicht
gleichsetzen denn es gibt eine tiefe
kluft zwischen den extremen reichenden
profitierten oligarchischen und der
breiten arbeitenden bevölkerung da muss
man differenzieren
sanktionen die die russische führung und
die oligarchen treffen sollen die finden
wir sehr sinnvoll aber das muss ich
ihnen sagen bei den sanktionen die sie
jetzt vornehmen wird sich leider zeigen
dass sie viel weniger wirkungsvoll sein
werden als es nötig wäre
weil die reichen und mächtigen russlands
längst mittel und wege haben sie zu
umgehen also durch gesetzeslücken und
mängel in der geldwäschebekämpfung ihre
investitionen hier bei uns im land in
europa im rest der welt verstecken
können zum beispiel ein geflecht von
briefkastenfirmen weil sie ihr geld in
der schweiz oder in steueroasen längst
in sicherheit gebracht haben das ist ein
problem kolleginnen kollegen
aber dieses problem muss man jetzt
ändern geldwäsche kann wirksam bekämpft
werden steueroasen können ausgetrocknet
werden das muss jetzt geschehen damit
die sanktionen auch wirklich wirken
können
auch die russische rüstungsindustrie
darf nicht geschont werden darum
brauchen wir sofort einen lieferstopp
von gütern insbesondere im
hightech-bereich die verrichtung
verwendet werden können die sind nach
wie vor große lücken die dringend
geschlossen werden müssen denn auch hier
drohen die maßnahmen sonst zahnlos zu
sein
kolleginnen und kollegen beim thema
nation muss man sich aber auch ehrlich
machen und daher geht es ausdrücklich
nicht dass einzelne interessen von
einflussreichen lobbys berücksichtigt
werden ohne dass es irgendeine sachliche
erklärung gibt und wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel erfahre das italienische luxus
artikel aus dem sanktionskatalog
herausfallen dann muss ich mich schon
fragen welche prioritäten gesetzt werden
das geht
kolleginnen kollegen die bilder die wir
jeden tag sehen die meldungen die
behören die machen uns betroffen und wir
sehen aktuell noch keinen weg wie die
menschen in der ukraine
schnell ein leben in frieden frieden und
freiheit führen können ja wir brauchen
sofort einen waffenstillstand
und auch wenn es uns aktuell vielleicht
unmöglich erscheint muss unser handeln
klar von dem gedanken getragen sein dass
der tag kommt an dem man den
verhandlungstisch zurückkehren muss
eine lehre sollte sein dass wir uns
unabhängiger machen besonders von
diktatorischen regimen und dass das
völkerrecht und die menschenrechte
wichtiger sind als wirtschaftliche
interessen
in ihrer mohammed ali für die
linksfraktion der bundeskanzler hat von
einer zeitenwende gesprochen von einer
zeitenwende da muss man wohl auch bei
den linken sprechen das war hier eine
klare schuld zuschreibung was die kriegs
ursachen angeht in richtung klar die mir
putin ein bekenntnis von
fehleinschätzungen in den vergangenen
monaten aber auch eine neue offenheit
sanktionen gegenüber sie müssten halt
die richtigen treffen sagt amira
mohammed ali und für die spd-fraktion
spricht jetzt deren vorsitzender rolf
mützenich
sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der vom
russischen präsidenten
befohlene überfall auf die ukraine ist
eine entsetzliche barbarei
putin will ein volk und eine eine
souveräne nation brechen er verantwortet
wissentlich und willentlich tod elend
und zerstörung
wir trauern mit den hinterbliebenen um
die opfer eines kriegsverbrechens dass
in diesen minuten in diesen stunden und
wahrscheinlich auch noch in den nächsten
tagen im vollen gange ist das ist putins
krieg
diese
diese zäsur meine damen und herren
bedeutet gleichwohl mehr der russische
präsident zerstört damit endgültig die
internationale ordnung die wir nach dem
kalten krieg errichten wollten vor
wenigen tagen haben sich die europäische
sicherheits ordnung aber auch die
internationale politik grundlegend
verändert
putins hochgerüstete militär und
atommacht verstößt abermals gegen das
intervention und gewalt verboten
deshalb sage ich von dieser stelle auch
an die welt heute ist eine nation auf
dem europäischen kontinent das opfer
morgen kann es auch ein land in
zentralasien treffen um die vermeintlich
russischen seelen einzusammeln wir
müssen gemeinsam gut in die stirn bieten
meine damen und herren mit vielen
regierungen mit vielen menschen so weit
wir können
und meine damen und herren der russische
überfall ist eine rückkehr zu einer
kriegerischen großmachtpolitik ist
besteht die gefahr eines flächenbrandes
wir sind der bundesregierung und unseren
verbündeten deshalb dankbar für die
klaren und eng
abgestimmten maßnahmen wir hoffen uns
die unterstützung von weiteren
regierungen außerhalb des westens
zugleich bin ich sicher meine damen und
herren dass die überwältigende mehrheit
der weltbevölkerung die aggression
verurteilt vor diesem hintergrund muss
sich vor allem die chinesische regierung
fragen wie lange sie die spannung
zwischen ihren aussenpolitischen
grundsätzen und einer mitleidlosen
interessenpolitik noch aushalten kann
präsident sie ändern sie ihren kurs
stoppen sie den krieg putins nur dann
kann china eine internationale ordnung
für den frieden in zukunft mit trägt
meine damen und herren
es war richtig dass der
un-sicherheitsrat vor zwei tagen
versucht hat die russische aggression
aufs schärfste zu verurteilen und das
rechte ukraine auf die territoriale
integrität und souveränität zu
bekräftigen russlands wto ändert daran
nichts putin hat sein vetorecht
moralisch und politisch verwirrt meine
damen und herren
umso wichtiger ist jetzt überweisung der
resolution in die generalversammlung der
vereinten nationen
hier sind fast alle länder versammelt
und das haus der staatenwelt könnte
morgen ein deutliches zeichen setzen
auch dafür meine damen und herren müssen
wir zusammen arbeiten hier im parlament
aber auch mit vielen regierungen auf der
welt
putin sollte die entschlossenheit und
den zusammenhalt der freien staatenwelt
nicht unterschätzen wir haben sanktionen
verhängt die nicht nur die russische
wirtschaft und das bankensystem
sondern auch putin seine kriegstreiber
und hasardeure treffen russland wird von
den internationalen finanzmärkten
ausgeschlossen es wird die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen der
sanktionen schmerzhaft spüren und auch
das sage ich auch wenn russland über
umfangreiche die diesen reserven verfügt
und seine kriegskasse gut gefüllt ist
putin und seine handlanger sollen wissen
langfristig wird das regime die
sanktionen spüren und das ist die klare
botschaft die heute auch hier aus berlin
in richtung moskau ausgesendet wird
meine damen und herren
dazu müssen die kommen und sagen einen
noch größeren unterstützerkreis schaffen
das heißt dann aber auch und auch das
sage ich sehr deutlich unser land ist
bereit die finanziellen und
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen zu tragen
darüber darf sich niemand heute hinweg
täuschen lassen sie mich es deutlich
sagen ja der krieg in der ukraine
bedeutet das scheitern aller bisherigen
diplomatischen bemühungen das ist
schmerzhaft und bitter
und da sage ich auch gerade für jemanden
der wie ich bis zum schluss alle
diplomatischen mittel nutzen wollte und
genutzt sehen wollte deshalb danke ich
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und
stellvertretend für die gesamte
bundesregierung annalena baerbock für
die unermüdliche arbeit ebenso wie den
französischen und dem amerikanischen
präsidenten dem britischen premier und
allen unseren freunden und partner die
nichts unversucht gelassen haben putin
von diesem schritt abzuhalten vielen
dank
hervorheben möchte ich auch die
weitgehende einigkeit in diesem haus von
der diplomatie über waffenlieferungen
bis hin zum bankensystem am ende unserer
debatte werden wir zusammen mit der
union eine gemeinsame
resolution verabschieden dass sie sein
starkes zeichen des zusammenhalts in
einer existenziellen krise dafür möchte
ich mich bei ihnen eher märz ganz
herzlich bedanken
mit der invasion wurden die hoffnungen
und die arbeit für eine friedlichere
welt auf jahrzehnte wahrscheinlich
zurückgeworfen
junge und nachfolgende generationen
werden uns dafür
verurteilen dass wir älteren ist nicht
vermocht haben eine bessere welt zu
schaffen sei es ein klima der armut oder
beim militär
und rüstung und ich kann für viele hier
in diesem haus versprechen solange wir
können müssen wir diese schuld abtragen
meine damen und herren wie unsicher
reichende missachtung internationaler
normen die einseitige kündigung von
abrüstungsverträgen und das
eigenmächtige verstörende auftreten
mancher staatschef in den letzten jahren
haben die welt nicht sicherer gemacht
nichts rechtfertigt putins krieg wir
müssen ihm grenzen setzen und neue
russische aggression eindämmen dafür
braucht es beides eine glaubhafte
verteidigung aber eben auch gemeinsam
eine kluge aussenpolitik meine damen und
herren und deswegen ja wir müssen die
bundeswehr in die lage versetzen diese
aufgabe gerecht zu werden unsere
streitkräfte müssen die ausrüstung
bekommen die sie brauchen deswegen haben
wir in den vergangenen jahren den
verteidigungshaushalt erhöht und wir
werden das auch in zukunft
verantwortungsvoll tun meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gleichzeitig und auch das
noch das sag ich in voller kenntnis
auch der großen herausforderung
gleichzeitig müssen wir das geld besser
und effizienter einsetzen kollege
lindner hat darauf hingewiesen auch
innerhalb der europäischen union und der
nato
allein vier europäer gehen jährlich über
200 milliarden euro für verteidigung aus
und deswegen sind wir überzeugt eine
effiziente verteidigungspolitik meine
damen und herren darf sich nicht in
ansätzen erschöpfen
auch wenn wir uns heute auch die
wehrhaftigkeit konzentrieren müssen
dürfen wir die anderen elemente einer
gerechten und demokratischen
sicherheitspolitik nicht vernachlässigen
deshalb war es ein gutes zeichen dass
wir noch am tag des russischen angriffs
zusätzlich fünf millionen euro für den
ukrainer hilfsfonds der vereinten
nationen bereit gestellt haben dies ist
eine botschaft an die kriegsflüchtlinge
die binnenflüchtlinge in der ukraine
aber auch die versuchen nach europa zu
kommen wir stehen ihnen in schwere not
zur seite auch durch die aufnahme in die
länder der europäischen union meine
damen und herren
unser respekt und unsere an gelten am
schluss meiner rede den mutigen
russischen staatsbürger die öffentlich
oder im sinn des zivilen ungehorsams die
barbarei ihres präsidenten vorurteil sie
zeigen damit der welt dass es ein
anderes russland gibt in russland das
teil der völkergemeinschaft sein möchte
und in frieden mit seinen nachbarn leben
vielen dank für die aufnahme
der vorsitzende der spd fraktion rolf
mützenich mit seiner rede in dieser ja
durchaus historischen sitzung des
deutschen bundestages bei der zwei
führende sozialdemokraten fehlen nämlich
der parteivorsitzende klingbeil und
bundesarbeitsminister heil und weil sie
ist beide selber öffentlich gemacht
haben kann man es sagen beide wegen
einer corona infektion heute an diesem
tag nicht hier alexander dobrindt es am
pult vorsitzender der csu landesgruppe
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen
der krieg ist im 21 jahrhundert in die
mitte europas zurückgekehrt
das unmögliche des wirklichkeit geworden
und ich weiß nicht was überwiegt wenn
man die bilder sieht wie leben von
jungen menschen in uniformen von frauen
und kindern in der zivilbevölkerung
zerstört wird ist es trauer oder ist es
die wut die einen erfasst aber eines
überwiegt sicher größer als der hass
dienst auch die ukraine ist unsere
solidarität mit den menschen und dem
volk der ukraine meine damen und herren
der bundeskanzler
sie haben in ihrer regierungserklärung
aus unserer sicht
richtig dargelegt dass der ausschluss
russlands aus dem swift finanzsystem
jetzt notwendig ist sie haben richtig
dargelegt dass die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine zu
unterstützen ist und wir waffen zu
liefern haben sie haben uns bei diesen
maßnahmen an ihrer seite sowohl was das
finanzsystem anbelangt als auch was die
lieferung von
verteidigungswaffen an die ukraine
betrifft wir haben seit mehreren tagen
festgestellt dass unsere partner in
europa dieses vorgehen auch von
deutschland eingefordert haben und wir
wollen im gleichklang mit unseren
europäischen und amerikanischen
partnern handeln und um dies auch
deutlich zu sagen es darf auch bei
weiteren notwendigen maßnahmen keinen
sonderweg deutschlands auf der bremse
geben dann haben sie uns weiterhin an
ihrer seite herr bundeskanzler
um auch das klarzustellen und für alle
unmissverständlich weil es natürlich
große debatten auch in der
öffentlichkeit darüber gibt wenn wir
waffen liefern in kriegsgebiete ja es
geht bei diesen lieferungen von waffen
uns nicht darum krieg zu führen es geht
darum verhandlungen wieder zu
ermöglichen und es zu schaffen dass
diejenigen die angegriffen sich auch
wehren können meine damen und herren
putin hat den frieden in europa zerstört
und wir müssen sehen dass unsere idee
frieden durch handel durch
wirtschaftliche verflechtung nicht
funktioniert hat wir waren uns sicher
dass der gemeinsame austausch von waren
dass der handel automatisch zu einem
friedlichen miteinander führt und es ist
auch nicht und es war auch nicht falsch
daran zu glauben aber es hat schlichtweg
nicht ausgereicht frieden zu sichern
braucht mehr als wirtschaftlicher stärke
frieden zu sichern braucht auch starke
sicherheitsgarantien und es braucht eine
starke verteidigungsfähigkeit meine
damen und herren
und ich hoffe dass wir in diesem
parlament einer meinung sind putin hat
nicht nur den frieden europas zerstört
putin hat auch die friedensdividende
zerstört politisch wirtschaftlich
gesellschaftlich haben wir in der
vergangenheit von dieser
friedensdividende
profitiert aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen setzte die es in diesem
parlament gegeben hat die geheißen haben
immer mehr ausrüstungen können nicht die
antwort sein diese sätze passen nicht
mehr in die zeit die antwort muss
zwingend heissen mehr ausrüstung mehr
militärtechnik und vor allem mehr
wertschätzung gegenüber unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten und der
bundeswehr liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und ja das hat sich abgezeichnet dass
die wachsenden aufgaben der bundeswehr
die auf sie zukamen und die mittel die
dafür bereit gestellt worden sind nicht
zusammenpassen ja es hat sich
abgezeichnet in der tat und der 24
februar der muss jedem klar sein das ist
die zäsur des landes und
bündnisverteidigung
wieder allerhöchste priorität haben muss
wie viele länder in europa verlassen
sich auf deutschland wenn es um die
bündnis garantien geht meine damen und
herren und wie viele in deutschland auch
in der politik glaubten dass die
sicherheitsgarantien im bündnis
alleinige aufgabe der vereinigten
staaten von amerika sind ich sage ihnen
wenn wir nicht wenn wir nicht die
sicherheit in europa garantieren wollen
warum sollten es dann die vereinigten
staaten von amerika tun
und deswegen will ich an dieser stelle
schon auch sagen
wenn man zuhört was hier von der linken
seite auch kommt das alles lässt sich in
frage stellt was wir gerade hier
diskutieren über die
verteidigungsfähigkeit und wer fähigkeit
europas der nato und der bundesrepublik
deutschland
ich glaube wir sollten das gemeinsame
bekenntnis abgeben wir brauchen für
unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit auch die nukleare
teilhabe und es ist unverantwortlich
diese nukleare teilhabe in frage zu
stellen meine damen und herren
in den letzten tagen und wochen war
immer wieder zu hören auch zu lesen
putin sei stark und der westen sei
schwach all denjenigen die so etwas
gesagt oder geschrieben haben ich kann
ihnen nur sagen unsere stärke ist nicht
einfach nur militärisch unsere stärke
ist vor allem auch demokratisch meine
damen und herren wenn der westen schwach
wäre dann würde putin ihn nicht fürchten
und würde nicht versuchen dass länder
wie die ukraine sich ihm anschließen
wollen wir sind deswegen stark war wie
für demokratie für wohlstand und für
freiheit steht das sind die werte die
putin seinem eigenen volk vorenthält und
deswegen dürfte jahren meine damen und
herren
europäische union und nato sichern
freiheit und wohlstand ihrer mitglieder
und deswegen wollen gerade auch die
länder aus dem ehemaligen ostblock sich
uns anschließen und sie wollen es auch
genau deswegen tun weil sie den
unterschied kennen zwischen einer
partnerschaft in der eu und der nato und
einer partnerschaft mit putin wir wollen
dass unsere freunde und partner auf
eigenen beinen in freiheit stehen können
putin will dass sie sich in den staub
werfen meine damen und herren wir
haben vor 70 jahren im deutschen
bundestag 1952 im februar
eine debatte über die wiederbewaffnung
der bundesrepublik deutschland geführt
es ging damals um den beitritt zur
europäischen
verteidigungsgemeinschaft
friedenspolitik heißt verzicht auf
politische ziele mit gewalt durchsetzen
zu wollen hat damals franz josef strauß
gesagt und weiter erklärt
friedenspolitik heißt aber auch einen
angreifer klar zu machen dass sein
angriff auf dem gesamt widerstand
europas stoßen wird dieser satz ist
heute so richtig wie damals wir können
den angriff auf die ukraine nicht mehr
verhindern aber wir können dafür sorgen
dass das nicht so weitergeht krieg und
gewalt dürfen schlichtweg nicht das
letzte wort in der geschichte sein
mandant hat gott schütze die ukraine
alexander dobrindt vorsitzender der
csu-landesgruppe und erster
stellvertretender vorsitzender
unionsfraktion unter anderem mit kritik
in richtung der linken und deren kritik
an der nuklearen teilhabe also der
stationierung von us atomwaffen in
deutschland das ist allerdings ein
konzept das auch in der spd nicht
unumstritten ist es kommt der dritte
minister in dieser debatte robert habeck
für bündnis 90 die grünen frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren erlauben sie auch mir noch ein
paar
einordnen bemerkung zur situation zum
handeln der bundesregierung und zu
diesen tagen wochenstunden und zu dieser
plenardebatte die sicherlich in zehn
jahren was historisch beurteilt werden
wird
ukraine heißt grenzland ein land am rand
von europa so sagt es der name einen
rang ein land am rand von russland und
immer wieder wurde seine territoriale
integrität
zerstört erobert nicht geachtet ein land
das so eine wechselvolle geschichte als
rand land als grenzland wie ist der name
ja selber sagt erlebt hat hat natürlich
manchmal probleme seine eigene
staatlichkeit zu entwickeln aber der
wille der menschen in der ukraine seit
30 jahren für die freiheiten für die
demokratie einzutreten ist
unerschütterlich geblieben und wir reden
hier nicht nur alleine über die
grenzfragen wir reden darüber ob der
wille zur freiheit und demokratie der
selbstbestimmung wille dieses landes
erhalten und verteidigt wird das
bedeutet die auseinandersetzung die wir
eigentlich gerade diskutieren und das
rechtfertigt auch die unbestreitbare
solidarität dieses hauses und dieser
bundesregierung mit der ukraine
es ist die freiheit
es ist die freiheit die putin züchtet
und er hat es selbst gesagt hat neben
bedeutung in einem gespräch mit dem
französischen präsidenten makro als ein
russisches kinder lee zitiert hat das
mädchen vorgelesen vorgesungen wird denn
die haarige manchmal ziehen wenn sie
gekämpft werden dass aber ein synonym
für vergewaltigung ist die ukraine
sollte ich nicht so anstellen sie würde
jetzt halt vergewaltigt werden so hat
der präsident gesprochen er weiß was er
tut und wer bei einer militärischen
vergewaltigung zuschaut macht sich
schuldig haben deswegen müssen wir
handeln und müssen wir unsere position
so stark machen dass wir der ukraine
helfen in dieser stunde der
militärischen vergewaltigungs not
es sind sicherlich rückblickend fehler
gemacht worden und auch das gilt es
aufzuarbeiten und auch das tun wir
gerade wenn man in der ukraine war dann
hat man die frustration an allen ecken
gespürt dass die haltung des westens
offenbar unklar war die tür ist offen
aber ihr dürft nicht durch wir halten an
unseren prinzipien fest aber bezahlen
sollen andere den kreis wir wollen gute
partnerschaft und handel durch wandel
aber wir sind nicht achtsam genug um zu
sehen in welcher abhängigkeit wir
geraten
beispielsweise durch die hohe
energiepolitische abhängigkeit
deutschlands von russischem öl kohle
oder gas importen man hatte also genug
waren die stimmen und wir waren
politisch nicht wachsam und nicht klar
genug darauf zu antworten
umgekehrt ist die deutsche geschichte
eine schwere hypothek
ukraine russland polen bilder russ wir
wissen ja gar nicht von welchem land für
uns zuerst entschuldigen sollen aufgrund
all der massaker der angriffskriege und
des südens von deutschen in diesen
ländern insofern achte nicht und ich
achte ass hoch eine position des
unbedingten pazifismus die sich
sicherlich auch aus dieser geschichte
ableitet und sagt wir können nicht
weiter nächste schuld auf uns lagen ich
achte aber ich halte es für falsch denn
schuldig werden wir trotzdem wir kommen
mit sauberen händen dann aus der sache
nicht raus deswegen ist die korrektur
die die bundesregierung gemacht hat also
die bereitschaft lachen zu liefern
richtig und sie ist richtig weil nur
eine position die sagen würde nur wenn
niemand waffen liefert ist alles richtig
also dass mir die ukraine alleine hoffen
wir darauf dass sie schnell überhand
wird die logisch konsequente position
ist die können wir aber oft genannten
nicht einnehmen deswegen so schwer es
ist es ist die richtige positionierung
und die richtige entscheidung aber
sie ist richtig aber
ob sie gut ist das weiß heute keiner und
ich weiß es auch nicht und ich habe mich
ja immer sehr offen dafür gezeigt diesen
schritt zu gehen
denn wer weiß schon wie sich der krieg
entwickelt und wer weiß ob aus dieser
entscheidung heraus nicht weitere
entscheidungen getroffen werden und hier
irgendwann lauter waffen liefern für
einen dauerhaften lang krieg in europa
auch das ist möglich wir müssen deswegen
uns leiten lassen von der
grundprinzipien frage warum wir uns auch
solche schweren auch uns an die grenze
führenden entscheidungen zumuten und
diese antwort kann nur in der
solidarität mit der freiheit und der
demokratie der völker und der menschen
stehen die für diese kämpfen das kann
aber konsequenzen haben und die
bundesregierung wird auch ich in meinem
amt alles dafür tun alles dafür tun die
konsequenzen auf deutschland den schaden
vom deutschen volk fernzuhalten wir
werden also für die bereiche der
wirtschaft die möglicherweise von
sanktionen betroffen sind ähnliche
schutzmaßnahmen machen wie wir es in der
korona kann debi getan haben wir werden
die reserven für kohle öl und gas
hochhalten und sind schon längst dabei
wir werden aber auch dem ausstieg aus
der verbrennung von fossilen energien
deutlich beschleunigen müssen und nicht
mehr über jahrzehnte reden an dieser
stelle wir werden also einen
ausstiegsplan aus dem passiven
vor dem mit großer kraft umsetzen wir
werden das gesetz die speicher voll zu
halten zeitnah vorlegen und ich werde
auch die fraktion zu gehen und sie
bitten dieses gesetz einzubringen damit
wir möglichst wenig zeit verlieren wir
werden einen hochlauf von wasserstoff
und erneuerbaren energien brauchen es
ist gut in die militärische sicherheit
zu investieren aber lassen sie mich an
dieser stelle klar sein die
energieversorgung und die souveränität
der energieversorgung ist ebenfalls eine
frage von nationaler sicherheit geworden
auch da rein werden wir investieren
müssen
der krieg ist in russland nicht populär
es gibt demonstrationen dagegen in 50
städten über tausend menschen sind am
ersten tag alleine verhaftet worden man
riecht sie förmlich die angst der
potentaten die angst vor putin vor
seinem eigenen volk und wenn wir uns
darüber klar machen worüber wir
entscheiden wann sehen wir ist hier was
den systemischen unterschied macht und
dass diesem tag was diese tage maskiert
markiert es ist die angst der potentaten
vor ihren eigenen menschen der den
unterschied macht es ist die angst der
autoritären vor ihrer eigenen
bevölkerung die den unterschied macht
hier die angst der machthaber dort der
mut zur freiheit die hoffnung auf
selbstbestimmung der mut auf die straße
zu gehen das macht den unterschied aus
das ist die provokation der freiheit die
für ihn und die seinen nicht aufhalten
insofern ist es eine systemfrage an der
wir heute stehen denken wir nicht nur
bis zur grenze denken wir darüber hinaus
seien wir in zukunft wachsam und nicht
arglos wenn wachsamkeit der preis der
freiheit ist dann wollen wir nicht
wieder schlafmützig sein setzen wir also
auf die freiheit vertrauen wir auf die
menschen und die menschlichkeit vielen
dank
herr minister
doch für harnik
nächster redner ist der kollege in
europa hat die fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
landsleute
lassen sie mich zu beginn eine
feststellung machen und allen vorrednern
auch dahingehend recht geben russland
hat die ukraine angegriffen und wir
haben wieder krieg in europa das
bestürzt mich als politiker bürger
deutschlands
und als familienvater zutiefst fest
steht dass die konflikt ursachen
mindestens acht jahre zurückliegen und
komplex sind es darf in diesen tagen
aber nicht unser ziel sein den einen
schuldigen auszumachen
wir müssen die diskussion auch da hin
zur lösung zu einer gemeinsamen zukunft
leiten im mittelpunkt im mittelpunkt
sollten jetzt genauso deutschland und
seine bürger stehen wie auch die rolle
der europäischen staaten und völker und
meine damen und herren russland ist
ebenso teil dessen wie die ukraine und
herr lindner es gibt immer hoffnung auf
hoffnung ein krieg und russland ist
ebensowenig lade mir putin wie
deutschland frank walter steinmeier ist
so einfach ist das nicht
und wir dürfen gerade in diesen tagen
russlands beitrag für deutschland und
europa eben nicht vergessen auch dadurch
wurde vor 32 jahren die deutsche einheit
ermöglicht untermauert durch den abzug
russischer truppen im jahr 1994 dem
müssen wir respekt zollen und das sage
ich ganz bewusst auch als ostdeutsche
wir danken russland bis heute dafür
liebe kollegen
schuldzuweisung und zuschreibungen
erzeugen keine lösung sondern heizen den
konflikt immer weiter an vielmehr stimme
ich allen rednern zu die sich für
deeskalation entschärfung in worten und
taten stark machen und ich rufe selbst
zur mäßigung auf wir alle wollen frieden
in deutschland und europa und deshalb
werden die bundesregierung versammeln
sie bitte alle partner am
verhandlungstisch verlassen sie den denk
korridor des ost west konflikt ist und
skizzieren sie eine gemeinsame zu des
europäischen kontinents dafür müssen wir
im dialog bleiben
mögliche
mögliche lösungen setzen zugeständnisse
auf beiden seiten voraus
und herr scholz sie haben heute leider
die kalten krieg reaktiviert mit ihrer
rede das muss ich so deutlich sagen
leider sehe ich im moment leider sehe
ich in einen moment und das habe ich in
den vorräten alles schon gehört ein
überbietungswettbewerb am schnellsten
und am effektivsten die brücken nach
osten abzubrechen zb die geldströme oder
nord stream wie herr bundeskanzler
scholz das möchte oder verkehrswege
sodass aeroflot nicht mehr landen darf
und da muss man würde die frage stellen
wem nutzt das wem nutzt das und welche
folgen er kaufen wir uns damit und
hernach sie haben von interessen
gesprochen welche interessen sie
verfolgen das wissen wir alle deutsche
interessen sind es definitiv nicht
und wir müssen fragen welche sozialen
folgen hat ihre politik für die
deutschen bürger diese müssen schon
jetzt überall mit steigenden preisen
leben lernen stichworte benzinpreise
heizkosten steigende inflation denken
sie mit auch daran welche signale sie
den nachfolgenden generationen geben
wollen sie allen ernstes die
bundesregierung sein die wir soldaten in
einen krieg gegen russland schickt das
lehnen wir ebenso ab wie die lieferung
von waffen in kriegsgebiete
werte kollegen wir als deutschland in
der mitte europas sind leidgeprüft und
gerade wir könnten mit unseren
erfahrungen eigenständig und
selbstbewusst für ein stabiles sicheres
europa aufdrehen und neutral in diesem
konflikt vermitteln und deshalb rufe ich
der bundesregierung zu planen sie nicht
die wir beziehung verschlechtern sondern
wie wir von wladiwostok bis lissabon
wohlstand sicherheit und eine friedliche
koexistenz aller nation garantieren
können wir brauchen stabilität
es darf auf keinen fall darin münden
dass sie schon jetzt die nächste
migrationswelle planen wer wie wir die
ukraine als eigenständigen staat
betrachtet muss sich auch für diesen
einsätzen und nicht dessen die
stabilisierung begünstigen meine damen
und herren bei allem streit für das gute
entpuppt sich eine scheinbar klare
position für freiheit und demokratie
auch mal als sackgasse
der chef der münchner philharmoniker
jähriger gf soll sich von russischer
politik distanzieren weil der russe ist
ich weiß nicht ob das für sie auch ein
repräsentant ist er soll sich bis montag
entscheiden ansonsten wird den
arbeitsplatz gekündigt ist das ein
einzelfall oder werden bald alle
russischen bürger in deutschland in
sippenhaft genommen das ist wirklich
unfassbar
und diese forderung diese forderung
stammt vom sozialdemokratischen
oberbürgermeister münchens dieter reiter
ideologie getriebene cancelled schafft
für freiheit und demokratie und wie es
dazu die position der bundesregierung
vor staatsministerin roth wien glaubt
man den damit zu treffen etwa putin das
ist reine macht symbolik und
unangemessen die zeiten in denen auge um
auge zahn um zahn galt sind vorbei meine
damen und herren ebenso wichtig wie die
deutsch-französische muss die deutsch
russische freundschaft sein
gegenseitiger achtung und respekt sind
die grundlage für eine gemeinsame
zukunft stabile verhältnisse auf einem
europäischen kontinent sind dabei in
unserem interesse ein neues wettrüsten
lehnen wir ab und deswegen diese 100
milliarden er soll es das ist wirklich
als fraktionsvorsitzender und
bundessprecher der alternative
deutschland werde ich mich persönlich
weiterhin für den dialog mit allen
verhandlungspartnern und für den frieden
einsetzen vielen dank
tino costa war dass der co vorsitzende
der fdp-fraktion im bundestag mit seiner
sicht des aktuellen
kriegsgeschehens und was da für die
ursachen sind allerdings vladimir putin
russischen präsidenten und
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
in einem atemzug zu nennen auf diese
idee muss man auch erst einmal kommen
christian dürr ist der nächste redner
vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion
verehrter herr präsident lieber
kollegen kollegen ich wollte eigentlich
nicht darauf eingehen aber
nicht dass wir worte der anteilnahme für
das ukrainische volk von der afg
erwartet hätten allerdings die realität
in europa so zu verzehren wie sie es
gerade getan haben ist niederträchtig
hervor
und ich will ihnen da fragen
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie nach außen das
beweist die mehrheit des deutschen
bundestages gerade aber sie ist es auch
nach innen gegen die feinde der
demokratie kommen das in aller klarheit
haben den kolleginnen kollegen
wladimir putin führt einen angriffskrieg
mitten in europa die ukraine hat putins
krieg nicht provoziert es gab in keinem
moment eine glaubwürdige bedrohung für
russland durch die ukraine wladimir
putins begründung für diesen krieg sind
auf desinformation auf propaganda und
lügen gebaut ist grenzt an zynismus wenn
der russische präsident behauptet ziel
seines angriffs sei eine
entnazifizierung der ukraine es ist
gelogen wenn er behauptet im don was für
über die ukraine eine genozid oder die
ukraine wolle nuklearwaffen um moskau zu
bedrohen meine damen und herren war ist
wladimir putin ist der aggressor in
diesem konflikt und das muss deutlich
ausgesprochen werden
der russische präsident bricht mit
seiner entscheidung zum angriff auf die
ukraine auch schwerste das völkerrecht
er bricht alle grundlegenden regeln der
internationalen ordnung die ksc
schlussakte von 1975 die charta von
paris von 1990 die bude das budapester
moment memorandum von 1994 die nato
russland grund akten von 1997
der 2008 verlängerte
freundschaftsvertrag der ukraine mit
russland und die charta der vereinten
nationen meine damen und herren werden
das bricht der ist ein verbrecher liebe
kollegen kollegen
und deshalb ist es richtig dass der
deutsche bundestag diesen angriffskrieg
der russischen des russischen
präsidenten auf das schärfste verurteilt
wir dürfen nicht schweigen wenn ein
souveränes mitglied der
staatengemeinschaft angegriffen wird
deshalb ist es richtig dass die
internationale gemeinschaft harte
konsequenzen zieht und umfassend
sanktionen verhängt gezielte sanktionen
insbesondere auch gegen die person
wladimir putin und sein umfeld um die
oligarchen und seine unterstützer zu
treffen und ich will dass in richtung
des bundeskanzlers und des
bundesfinanzministers sagen es war in
der gestrigen nacht eine richtige
entscheidung das scharfe schwert zu
ziehen und russlands banken von swift
abzukoppeln sie haben die ausdrückliche
unterstützung des deutschen bundestages
herr finanzminister der bundeskanzler in
dieser frage
und das gleiche gilt für die
waffenlieferung die in der gestrigen
nacht entschieden worden sind jedes
freie volk hat wenn es angegriffen wird
wird das recht sich zu verteidigen
unsere solidarität ist mit russland mit
der ukraine
unsere solidarität ist mit der ukraine
an dieser stelle eben auch über diesen
weg da kämpfen menschen gerade um ihr
leben und überleben soldaten verteidigen
irland das ist es deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir die ukraine mit
waffenlieferungen an dieser stelle
unterstützen zur verteidigung des
eigenen landes und von menschenleben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich will
an dieser stelle auch auf einen punkt
eingehen ich will auf ihre räder
eingehen herr merz ich fand das auch in
den letzten tagen auch miteinander
gesprochen ausdrücklich gut und
hilfreich dass die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
gesagt hat sie unterstützt die
bundesregierung bei dem was jetzt vor
uns liegt ein schwerer weg auch für
unser land und diese kooperation diese
einmütigkeit dafür danke ich ihnen sie
haben in ihrer rede gerade gesagt wir
stehen vor einem scherbenhaufen der
sicherheitspolitik ich teile diese
entscheidung und es geht christian
lindner hat ist vorhin gesagt nicht um
schuldzuweisung dabei sondern es geht um
gemeinsame verantwortung und deswegen
herr merz fordere ich sie auf tragen sie
diese gemeinsame verantwortung der
bundeskanzlerin der bundesfinanzminister
habe neben vorhaben skizziert wie wir
die verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres
landes im nato-bündnis stärken ich
fordere ihre fraktion auch dem
beizutreten und das auch mehrheitlich zu
unterstützen sollte eine zweidrittel
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag für eine
grundgesetzänderung nötig seien liebe
kollegen kollegen lieber bundeskanzler
herr finanzminister liebes kabinett ich
habe das starke gefühl sie haben für das
was sie hier vorgetragen haben die große
mehrheit des deutschen bundestages
hinter sich und das ist ein ganz
wichtiges signal vor dem hintergrund
dieses konflikts in die welt liebe
kollegen verlieh
und ich will an der stelle sagen
kann ist dass alle bewegt
ein europa in dem nicht
dem streit nicht mit krieg sondern
friedlich gelöst wird ist ein europa so
wie wir es uns vorstellen und es ist ein
europa wie deutschland dazu beigetragen
hat ist nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
aufzubauen viele haben gesagt putins
angriff ist ein angriff auf ganz europa
doch es ist in wahrheit vielmehr ein
angriff auf die gesamte menschheit auf
das grundrecht jeder person in frieden
und freiheit zu leben wir stehen an der
schwelle eines neuen jahrhunderts in dem
dieser hart erkämpften rechte weltweit
bedroht werden deswegen ist der krieg in
der ukraine ein krieg für die rechte
aller menschen und überall hinter der
ukraine steht nicht nur die europäische
union und europa sondern die ganze
demokratische welt sowie all diejenigen
die woanders gegen autokratische staaten
für freiheit kämpfen meine damen und
herren es geht um die freiheit in der
welt an dieser stelle und deswegen steht
die bundesrepublik deutschland als
liberale demokratie an der seite des
ukrainischen volkes und herr botschafter
ich will sie an der stelle direkt
ansprechen der deutsche bundestag die
menschen in deutschland leiden derzeit
mit ihrem volk wir stehen solidarisch an
der seite der demokratischen
institutionen und dem ukrainischen volk
auch das ist eine botschaft des der
sondersitzung des deutschen bundestages
an dem heutigen tage herrn botschafter
und zum schluss liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
will ich auch ein wort richten an das
russische volk ich weiß dass viele
gerade überlegen auf die straße zu gehen
viele menschen in russland sind bereits
verhaftet worden weil sie sich gegen das
autokratische regime von wladimir putin
stellen wir wollen den menschen an
dieser stelle in russland auch sagen wir
haben höchsten respekt für diejenigen
die sich gegen wladimir putin auflehnen
die in den letzten tagen laut gegen den
krieg in die eu in der ukraine
gesprochen haben und in russland auf die
straßen gehen auch diese menschen haben
unsere ausdrückliche solidarität liebe
kollegen kollegen
die als deutsche wie einst europäer wir
dürfen uns nicht kleinreden europa ist
ein sehnsuchtsort unser demokratisches
system ist ein symbol der hoffnung für
viele und gemeinsam liebe kolleginnen
kollegen gemeinsam sind wir stärker als
die kraft der autor krieg und der
kriegstreiberei ich dagegen
christian über die höhe der fdp fraktion
unter anderem mit einem appell an die
union entscheidungen mitzutragen zum
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das im
grundgesetz verankert werden soll und
deshalb eine zwei drittel mehrheit
braucht hier im parlament diese
zustimmung auch da muss man kein
besonders großer prophet sein diese
zustimmung wird es aus der union nicht
ganz umsonst geben die nächste rednerin
in dieser debatte ist saskia esken co
vorsitzender der spd
herr präsident
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
der russische machthaber wladimir putin
hat mit abscheulicher arroganz das
völkerrecht gebrochen und die ukraine
überfall
putin hat den krieg und das
blutvergießen in europa wieder ins hier
und jetzt geholt in einem jetzt an dem
ganz europa gemeinsam gearbeitet hat aus
verantwortung vor krieg und leid in
unserer geschichte damit es uns damit
ist unseren kindern und enkeln heute und
morgen ein leben in frieden ermöglicht
doch nun haben wir krieg in europa
und dieser krieg ist putins krieg putin
führt diesen krieg gegen die ukraine
doch vor allem führt er diesen krieg
gegen das was er als diktator am meisten
fürchtet demokratie und freiheit
und so stehen die farben der ukraine die
farben europas heute auch für demokratie
und freiheit und die sind stärker als
das autoritäre welt mit des russischen
diktators
in russland in georgien in ganz europa
den menschen auf die strassen gegen
diesen krieg und für den frieden putin
führt krieg auch gegen die menschen im
eigenen land tausende wurden
festgenommen die proteste durch die
russische staatsgewalt brutalen
niedergeschlagen die
friedensdemonstrationen wie sie gerade
heute in berlin und anderswo in
deutschland in europa stattfinden geben
auch denjenigen eine stimme die nicht
sprechen können ohne ihr leben zu
gefährden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
nicht erst seit putins überfall sind
menschen in unserer mitte in unserer
mitte in großer sorge um ihre mütter und
väter ihre brüder und schwestern
freundinnen freunde in der ukraine und
in russland
sie halten kontakt sie leisten beistand
sie versorgen die menschen mit
verlässlichen informationen doch seit
dem 24 februar sind die antworten auf
ihre anrufe und nachrichten spärlich
geworden denn die menschen sind auf der
flucht sie verstecken sich sie müssen
leise sein weil sie angst haben entdeckt
zu werden sie schreiben wenn sie können
kurznachrichten und hektisch
geschriebene hilfe rufen das sind
zeugnisse voller sorge und angst sorge
und angst auch um die soldatinnen und
soldaten die hier leben und viel land
kämpfen und doch scheint auch immer
wieder hoffnung durch hoffnung darauf
dass ukrainerinnen und ukrainer in ihrer
heimat bald wieder in frieden und
freiheit leben können
putin führt in der ukraine einen krieg
gegen die menschen und er führt einen
krieg gegen die menschlichkeit
der überfall auf die ukraine ist
insofern eine zäsur in erbricht mit den
grundprinzipien der internationalen
gemeinschaft es ist unsere vordringliche
aufgabe diesen blutigen krieg so schnell
wie möglich zu beenden
deshalb werden die sanktionen der
internationalen gemeinschaft nochmals
geschärft und dabei kommt es
entscheidend darauf an unkalkulierbare
auswirkungen auf die bevölkerung
abzuwenden oder sie wo nötig auch
auszugleichen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
die maxime deutscher außenpolitik keine
waffen in krisengebiete zu liefern ist
tief in unserer historischen
verantwortung verwurzelt
dass die bundesrepublik deutschland
jetzt waffen an die ukraine zur
selbstverteidigung liefert ist in dieser
situation eine tragische notwendigkeit
und moralisch geboten
diese entscheidung schulden wir der
solidarität mit der ukrainischen
bevölkerung und wir schulden sie unseren
geteilten europäischen werten von
demokratie und freiheit
und bundeskanzlers scholz hat deshalb
meinen tiefen respekt und meine
anerkennung diese schwierige
entscheidung von großer tragweite
verantwortungsvoll getroffen zu haben
mit unserer bundeswehr werden wir als
mitglied von nato und europäischer union
für die sicherheit in europa unseren
beitrag leisten darauf ist verlass heute
und in der zukunft unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten haben unseren tiefen
respekt um ihre aufgabe erfüllen zu
können müssen sie bestmöglich
ausgestattet sein dafür auch dafür steht
diese bundesregierung
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die menschen in europa sind in großer
solidarität an der seite der ukraine und
sichern ihre hilfe zu für viele
schutzsuchende ist polen der erste
sichere hafen und erhält dafür im rahmen
der eu auch alle notwendige
unterstützung
auch viele deutsche städte können und
wollen sichere häfen seien denen
menschen die sich hier solidarisch
zeigen die anpacken und helfen wollen
gilt mein großer dank
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
demokratie und freiheit immer obsiegen
werden dafür werden menschen immer und
zu jeder zeit bereit sein zu kämpfen
unsere gedanken sind in dieser schweren
zeit bei unseren freundinnen und
freunden in der ukraine die in diesen
tagen freiheit und demokratie
verteidigen vielen dank
der
spd-vorsitzende quasi in
anführungszeichen jetzt aber wirklich in
vertretung von lars klingbeil der ja
eigentlich die außenpolitik gespielt in
der spd spitze aber da lars klingbeil
wegen einer corona infektion heute an
dieser sitzung nicht teilhaben kann
jetzt also saskia esken zu diesem thema
patricia lips ist die nächste rednerin
kommt aus der unionsfraktion und ist der
stellvertretende vorsitzende
herr präsident kolleginnen und kollegen
gehört es in vielen reden es ist krieg
nicht irgendwo weit weg sondern mitten
in europa
und es zeigt sich wie schön es ist wie
einfach es ist ein hohelied auf europa
zu sehen sich zu freuen zu bekennen die
europäische union als das größte
friedensprojekt in der nachkriegszeit
die bedeutung jetzt zu erkennen aber
kolleginnen und kollegen es gilt auch
die bewährungsprobe ist jetzt und ich
danke dass wir hier in dieser form
zusammen stehen hier im haus jetzt in
deutschland und auch innerhalb der
europäischen union ein nachbar wird
angegriffen es wird bewusst leid und
zerstörung in kauf genommen heute ist es
die ukraine aber sollte der plan
gelingen so möchten wir uns doch nicht
ausmalen
dieses vorgehen wo es als präzedenzfall
ebenfalls in die tat umgesetzt würde ob
durch putin an weiteren grenzen seines
landes oder einem andern aggressor
anderswo auf der welt machen wir uns
bewusst welche gedanken und sorgen in
diesen tagen vor allem auch die menschen
in vilnius in prag und warschau
beschäftigen kriegsangst geht um und
welche erwartungen hoffnungen sie mit
uns verbinden die letzten tage und
stunden haben es gezeigt man schaut auf
uns deshalb lassen sie uns diese
hoffnungen nicht enttäuschen nicht
weiter enttäuschend ist man leider
versucht zu sagen es geht um solidarität
mit den menschen in der ukraine
überall finden kundgebungen und
mahnwachen mit tausenden von menschen
statt an vielen stellen erstrahlen die
nationalfahnen der ukraine unsere
gedanken sind bei den menschen in diesem
land aber kolleginnen und kollegen
solidarität braucht auch glaubwürdigkeit
wir sehen väter die sich von ihren
familien verabschieden männer die
unzureichende bewaffnet gegen panzer
kämpfen ein präsident der zum ausdruck
bringt ich bin da ich bleibe bei euch
bilder die gerade um die welt gehen
freiheit ist nicht selbstverständlich
wir haben es bereits heute mehrfach
gehört sie hat ihren preis für die
menschen in der ukraine wird dieser
preis aktuell mit der angst um ihr
eigenes leben bezahlt vergessen wir
nicht sie kämpfen diesen kampf auch für
uns der angriff auf dieses land ist ein
angriff auf unser aller wertesystem
und wenn wir heute über sanktionen reden
auch solche die auswirkungen auf uns
selbst haben dann muss uns die
verteidigung dieser werte immer
gegenwärtig seien kolleginnen und
kollegen der afd wir kennen unsere werte
wir wissen sie wir verteidigen was ihre
werte sind da machen wir hin und wieder
ein fragezeichen dahinter seit gestern
nachmittag macht sich erleichterung
breit innerhalb und außerhalb europas
deutschland hat klar gemacht wenn auch
spät unser platz ist an der seite
unserer bündnispartner
es kann gar nicht anders sein wir
begrüßen deshalb dass die
bundesregierung ihre haltung bei swift
stichwort internationaler
zahlungsverkehr wie auch bei den
waffenlieferungen mit defensiven
charakter aufgegeben hat kolleginnen und
kollegen wir bedauern gleichwohl dass es
hierfür erst eine welle der empörung
gebraucht
wir müssen den mut haben
alles an maßnahmen aufzufahren unterhalb
der schwelle einer eigenen militärischen
auseinandersetzung nicht wir nicht die
ukraine führen einen angriffskrieg aber
wir müssen instrumente an hand geben
geeignete instrumente um
zwischenzeitlich auch leben zu schützen
zu verteidigen und größtmöglichen druck
auszuüben es geht darum weiteres leid
und zerstörung zu vermeiden so es
möglich ist ein stopp schild
aufzustellen
wann wenn nicht jetzt kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist unsere pflicht die
ukraine zu unterstützen so bundeskanzler
olaf scholz am gestrigen tag das galt
jedoch von spätestens zu beginn der
vergangenen woche deshalb zeigen sie
auch weiterhin dass sie den worten
insbesondere des heutigen tages taten
folgen lassen und wir unserer
verantwortung gerecht werden ich sage
ihnen zu dann haben sie uns an ihrer
seite ich schließe mit den worten des
ukrainischen nationaldichter taras
schewtschenko
unserer seele unser lied wird nicht
sterben wird nicht verschwinden
darin leute liegt unser
programm botschafter und danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank patricia lips
stellvertretende vorsitzende der cdu csu
cdu csu fraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag mit ihrer rede es ist ein
besonderer tag manche sagen ein
dramatischer tag auch manche sagen es
wird ein tag sein mit weitreichenden
auswirkungen auf die deutsche außen- und
sicherheitspolitik und ein wenig
spiegelt sich das auch im licht wenn sie
mal schauen auf die redner rennen am
pult eine ganz besondere lichtstimmung
hat sich durch die sonneneinstrahlung
auf das parlament gelegt britta
haßelmann für die fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen
ich glaube auch das macht es aus was
heißt mit uns allmacht und mit den
menschen im land es ist eine unfassbare
tragödie
unsere gedanken sind dort die trauer
schon jetzt über die toten dieses
sinnlosen krieges ist groß bei den
familien bei den angehörigen bei den
freundinnen und freunden bei den
menschen die auf der flucht sind in
großer angst über ihre zukunft und ihre
sicherheit wir alle wissen und können
uns in die lage versetzen was es für uns
alle heißen würde was menschen dort
gerade durchleben und das macht die
tragik und dramatik aus meine dann kann
ich bin fassungslos wenn ich die bilder
von zerstörten häusern von menschen die
in schutz den schutz in der u-bahn wie
hier brandenburger tor suchen ja bei
menschen die freunde haben in sorge sind
um ihre angehörigen in der ukraine die
eigentlich alle etwas ganz einfaches
wollen etwas selbstverständnis nämlich
frei und selbstbestimmt zu leben wie wir
alle ich frage mich wirklich jeden tag
was tätig wie ginge es mir wie ginge es
meiner familie
wenn ich sehe dass junge menschen sich
bewaffnen lassen weil sie denken sie
müssen jetzt auch als bürgerinnen und
bürger des landes der ukraine ihren land
verteidigen und für freiheit kämpfen und
darum geht's meine damen und herren und
nicht um fraktion im sport verdammt noch
mal das ist doch völlig verfehlt in
dieser debatte
gut
nun in
verzweiflung über diesen barbarischen
unmenschlichen krieg und die
ungewissheit und die vielen fragen weil
seit dem 24
februar ist die welt nicht mehr die
gleiche und das spüren die menschen im
land und das sage ich auch in ihre
richtung herr merz wie können sie sich
so lächerlich machen über menschen die
an lichterketten und mahnwachen
teilnehmen wie auch heute wieder überall
im land es ist unser privileg hier in
deutschland willkommen und dort reden zu
dürfen ja über diese lange aber andere
menschen bürgerinnen und bürger dieses
landes sterben vielleicht nur diese eine
ausdrucksform über ihre verzweiflung
ihre besorgnis und ihre solidarität herr
botschafter zur ukraine und das ist
vielleicht die teilnahme an einer
lichterkette ich rate ihnen sagen sie so
was nie wieder
wir haben eine verantwortung meine damen
und herren und die nehmen wir wahr die
nehmen wir als nationales parlament
europäisch und im transatlantischen
bündnis ja und viele gewissheiten die
ich habe die meine fraktion hat die alle
demokratischen kräfte in diesem land
haben die sind vielleicht nicht mehr die
gewissheiten die wir noch gestern oder
vor dem 24 februar und wir alle wissen
es verlangt uns wirklich viel ab wir
werden über vieles diskutieren müssen
die welt ist eine andere
wir müssen über den schutz und die
aufnahme von geflüchteten menschen reden
und zwar ohne wenn und aber denn auch
das heißt europa zusammen stehen für
humanitäre hilfe und den schutz der
menschen das ist das was wir ihnen
entgegen können die türen sind auch und
keller und andere da sind sie weit weg
sie sind außerhalb dieses demokratischen
diskurses an dieser stelle die türen
sind auch in europa für die menschen
weil wir alle könnten in der gleichen
situation seien angesichts eines solchen
eklatanten bruchs des völkerrechts und
das wissen wir und spüren wir und es
gibt eine bereitschaft bei den
bürgerinnen dafür dass mitzutragen weg
zu ja offen zu sein dafür und dass es
gut wir müssen über die frage der
ernährungssicherung reden wir müssen
über die energieversorgung reden und ja
wir werden auch über den
verteidigungsetat und die fragen was
notwendig ist reden aber die
entscheidung und der ort der debatte ist
hier im parlament meine damen und herren
und da bin ich ganz sicher
und ich danke an dieser stelle für die
klare haltung und auch die vorbereitung
der bundesregierung für das harte
sanktionspaket auch die abkopplung von
swift zielgenau war notwendig das
treffen der zentralbank der russischen
wird enorme auswirkungen haben und ich
bin auch der auffassung wie meine
fraktion dass an der stelle die frage
der machen lieferung und des
selbstbestimmungsrechts der ukraine sehr
sehr große bedeutung haben und deshalb
war auch dieser schritt notwendig und
wichtig in dieser schwierigen situation
banken
können foto lehmann
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
piotr bistro die fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
exzellenz ja
russland führt ein angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine und wir haben hier sehr viel
über die verantwortung von wladimir
putin an diesen krieg gerat und putin
wird sich auch verantworten müssen vor
den russischen wlan vor den russischen
bürgern aber unsere bürger wollen wissen
welche rolle hat die deutsche
bundesregierung in der vergangenheit
gespielt und wie wird sie sich hier
jetzt verantworten
und herr bundeskanzler scholz ich habe
in ihren ausführungen die
selbstreflektion vermisst genauso wie
bei der cdu sie haben die letzten acht
jahre regiert sie haben ukraine
finanziert seit acht jahren in
deutschland ist der zweitgrößte
nettozahler und sie haben kein einziges
mal diese zahlungen daran geknüpft dass
die ukraine die minsk zwei abkommen dass
sie das abkommen auch erfüllt und darin
ging es um autonomie es ging lediglich
um autonomie
jetzt ist das vom tisch jetzt ist die
autonomie frage vom tisch jetzt haben
wir krieg und daran tragen sie die
mitverantwortung
sie haben acht jahre lang der ukraine
falsche versprechen gemacht sie haben
sie die in die eu und in die nato
gelockt und jetzt wo der krieg da ist wo
ist denn postern jetzt ihre
verantwortung sie haben die werte die
demokratie die wollten sie mal mit der
waffe sogar in hindukusch verteidigen
jetzt ist der krieg in europa jetzt
können sie in vereinen verteidigen und
was machen sie gar nichts sie haben
programme immer nur als spielball auf
der geopolitischen karte missbraucht ihr
ganzes wert der geräte war pure
heuchelei und
was was jetzt kommen sie mir nicht mit
den sanktionen ich bitte sie die russen
haben die sanktionen mit eingepreist die
sagen ich will das ja gar nicht zitieren
was botschafter in schweden gesagt hat
und dass herr lindner gesagt hat
schulden sind freiheit das hat dem man
damals an der liberalen partei war also
liebe freunde schulden sind nicht
freiheit schulden sind knechtschaft
jeder euro von diesen 100 milliarden die
sie rausgehen werden werden arbeiten den
bürgern in deutschland über steuern
abgepresst
und was haben sie erreicht sie haben das
gesagt herr bundeskanzler scholz die
einflusssphäre hat sich verschoben ja
welche einfluss wäre die nato hat sich
verschoben an die grenze russland die
amerikanische einflusssphäre hat sich
richtung russische grenze verschoben und
was ist der preis dafür junge männer
sterben es sind kleiner genauso wie
russen sterben jetzt und tiere politisch
haben sie russland in die hände von
china getrieben russland war immer eine
europäische macht und sie haben sie in
die umarmung von china getrieben
und sagen sie nicht sie waren nicht
gewarnt es warten genauso die russen
schon vor 15 jahren platini putin hat
hier gesprochen im deutschen bundestag
damals wurde beklatscht er hat 2007 bei
der siko in münchen gesprochen hat uns
eine gemeinsame sicherheitsarchitektur
angeboten
und sie haben das alles ausgeschlagen
ihre eigene leute
haben sie gewarnt hatten wir als
schönbach noch vor einem monat das alles
haben sie ausgeschlagen sie haben alle
warnungen ignoriert und das ergebnis ist
krieg in europa und dafür tragen auch
sie eine mitverantwortung
der bundestag diskutiert über die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
zur lage in der ukraine zum krieg in der
ukraine so zum angriff der zum angriff
russlands auf die ukraine und die folgen
der hat der bundestags-vizepräsident
noch nachgeschoben auch solche reden
zeigten den unterschied zwischen einem
parlament in freiheit und einem
parlament ohne freiheit und ruft auf den
ministerpräsidenten von brandenburg
dietmar woidke
auch daniel günther der
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
hatte über eine längere strecke an
dieser sitzung teilgenommen verehrte
abgeordnete dass ich mal an einer stelle
stehe und sage dass die brandenburger
auf die fraktion beispiel gebend war was
die
verurteilung des überfalls russlands auf
die ukraine betrifft das hätte ich mir
vor wenigen minuten noch nicht
vorstellen können aber nach dem was hier
gesagt worden ist muss ich das leider
sagen es ist ein skandal wie sie von der
fdp fraktion mit dieser krise umgehen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
nach jahrzehnten des krieges in nach
jahrzehnten des friedens gibt es wieder
krieg in europa es ist eine tragödie für
die menschen in der ukraine
es bringt leid es bringt tod es ist aber
auch eine tragödie für die menschen in
russland wir erleben einen eklatanten
bruch des völkerrechts wir erleben den
versuch den lauf der geschichte
tiere mit militärischen mitteln zu
verändern und wir erleben den versuch
die demokratische entwicklung in einem
unabhängigen land mit
militärischer gewalt zu verhindern
es ist ein
verbrecherischer krieg den der russische
präsident vom zaun gebrochen hat es ist
ein krieg gegen
die demokratie und gegen die freiheit
und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren es ist ein krieg gegen uns alle
stehen fest an der seite der ukraine
diese aggression wird ihre ziele nicht
erreichen nicht in der ukraine aber auch
nicht in europa die menschen in
deutschland die menschen in brandenburg
wollen frieden wir wollen freundschaft
mit anderen völkern
besonders auch mit dem russischen volk
viele die sich in den letzten
jahrzehnten für gute beziehung zu
russland beispielsweise in schul
städtepartnerschaften bei wirtschafts
oder sport projekten eingesetzt haben
sind heute tief enttäuscht verbittert
und frustriert und ich gebe zu das
betrifft auch mich persönlich
ich hätte mir noch vor wenigen wochen
nicht vorstellen können dass am 24
februar dieses jahres realität geworden
ist auch ich wenn tief enttäuscht von
dem was in den letzten tagen passiert
ist aber ich glaube gerade in dieser
schweren zeit ist es notwendig die
menschen zu ermuntern sich weiterhin für
starke kontakte in die russische
zivilgesellschaft
einzusetzen es ist eben nicht
das russische volk das krieg in der
ukraine führen es ist ein präsident der
mit seiner clique diesen krieg vom zaun
gebrochen hat und deswegen müssen wir
weiter versuchen auch wenn es schwierig
wird und wenn es schwierig ist brücken
zu bauen denn wer diese brücken nicht
gebaut werden hat präsident putin
gewonnen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich habe mich in den letzten
tagen häufig an eine veranstaltung am
dritten beides jahres 2009 10 in bad
freienwalde erinnert ich habe damals mit
seiner exzellenz dem russischen
botschafter eine neu gestaltete
gedenkstätte für sowjetische opfer des
zweiten weltkrieges eingeweiht das
besondere an dieser gedenkstätte ist das
1400 gefallene ihren namen und ihre
geburtsdaten
zurückbekommen haben
1400 gefallene soldat in unsere daten
der damaligen sowjetischen armee die mit
diesen daten ihre identität zurück
bekommen haben sie haben ihren namen
zurückbekommen und mit dem namen wird
jedem klar es liegt eben hier nicht der
unbekannte soldat sondern es liegt hier
andre
potter-fan
oder alex c
und jeder
einzelne von ihnen war ein sohn ein
bruder ein ehemann
und ein freund
und weniger von den 1400 die in bad
freienwalde beerdigt worden sind waren
älter als
20 jahre
und genau jetzt genau heute genau zu
dieser stunde
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
sterben wieder menschen in einem krieg
und diese toten in bad freienwalde auch
an vielen anderen stellen die 25
millionen toten die die sowjetunion als
blutzoll im zweiten weltkrieg zu
bezahlen hatte mahnen uns heute sie
fordern den russischen präsidenten auf
sie rufen ihn zu nie wieder krieg auch
im namen der menschen die im zweiten
weltkrieg gestorben ist herr präsident
putin
stoppen sie sofort die aggression gegen
die ukraine stoppen sie das morgen
stoppen sie den krieg dann gesehen
das ist eine besondere debatte heute in
den deutschen bundestag es ist ein
besonderer tag aufgrund der
entscheidungen gestern damit
entscheidungen die die deutsche politik
verändern werden und es ist der tag des
eingestehen von fehlern schätzungen
haben es eben von dietmar woidke gehört
dem brandenburger ministerpräsidenten
auch von amira mohammed ali aus der
linksfraktion
vor wenigen wochen noch so hatte dietmar
wort wie gesagt hätte ich mir nicht
vorstellen können dass seine 24 februar
geschehen ist von johann wadephul für
die unionsfraktion er journalist sollten
wir auch die debatte miteinander führen
sie hat gezeigt dass es richtig ist in
dieser situation zusammenzustehen
bundeskanzler hat dazu heute eine
bemerkenswerte rede gehalten
das ist ein geopolitischer amoklauf den
präsidenten putin hier veranstaltet und
dem müssen wir uns in der mitte des
hauses gemeinsam
entgegenstellen und
die debatte hat erneut gezeigt dass
links und rechts in diesem haus
parlamentariern parlamentarier sitzen
die ihrer aufgabe nicht gerecht werden
sie muss insbesondere sagen was wir hier
an stimmen aus der fdp fraktion heute
wieder gehört haben
schlägt dem fass den boden aus es ist
widerlich anhören zu müssen dass sie
angesichts dieses angriffskrieges sogar
in der bundesregierung eine
mitverantwortung sehen wollen angesichts
der begründung die der russische
präsident für seinen angriff ski gibt
gegeben hat es müsse eine
entnazifizierung in der ukraine
stattfinden die von einem präsidenten
mit jüdischer abstammung geführt wird
das ist an perfidie nicht zu überbieten
und wir müssen zusammenstehen als
demokratinnen und demokraten damit die
leute wieder verantwortung übernehmen
wir müssen gemeinsam handeln und das ist
genau das und deswegen glaube ich auch
wir sind alle aufgefordert hier
gemeinsam zusammenzustehen auch in der
mitte des hauses und deshalb nachhaltige
aufforderung in unsere richtung gegeben
das zu machen die cdu csu fraktion ist
im geiste der bisherigen beratungen dazu
bereit und ich schlage vor frau kollegin
dass wir hier an der stelle uns auch
nicht auseinander trennen und ist genau
das was friedrich merz auch heute
angeboten hat und dass wir natürlich
machen ohne aufgabe unserer
parlamentarischen oppositionellen rechte
wir kennen uns ja aus vielen jahren wo
sie hier als
wirklich strikte wahrnehmen auch von
oppositionellen rechten aufgetreten sind
die cdu deutschlands hat gestern und da
hat friedrich merz gesprochen eine
mahnwache gehalten und das hat er hier
heute als gut befunden
der punkt ist der punkt ist ja deswegen
will ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen war es
absolut daneben uns so etwas vorzuwerfen
wenn man so etwas nicht vorwerfen kann
ist es der cdu unter führung von
friedrich merz
der punkt ist nur wir müssen eben
gemeinsam handeln
und einen großen handlungsstark bereich
im bereich der verteidigungspolitik hat
der herr bundeskanzler angesprochen und
hat hier das wort bei super passt jetzt
an der stelle nicht weil das haben sie
ein anderer stelle mal benutzt und ich
will es ausdrücklich nicht verwenden
aber für die bundeswehr eine finanzielle
ausstattung zugesagt zwei prozent wird
niemals mehr unterschritten werden und
100 milliarden in einem sondervermögen
das ist eine große ansagen und darüber
können wir miteinander reden nur mir
fällt auf dass außerdem
fraktionsvorsitzender freien demokraten
bisher keine parteivorsitzende und kein
parteivorsitzender und kein
fraktionsvorsitzender der spd aus den
koalitionsfraktionen dieser ankündigung
begrüßt und unterstützt hat das fällt
mir auf liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und die zurückhaltung in der grün
fraktionen die zurückhaltung in der
grünen fraktion als der herr
bundeskanzler genau das gesagt hat die
ist schon sehr auffällig gewesen sie
haben uns bei sich wenn wir jetzt
geschlossen reagieren sie haben uns bei
sich wenn es um die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen
aber wir müssen auch zusammenstehen wenn
es konkret wird und nicht dass es wieder
losgeht mit gruppen anträgen benzin wenn
es um die förderung der bundeswehr und
den verteidigungsetat da brauchen wir
brauchen sie ihre eigene mehrheit da
verlangen wir von ihnen dass sie stehen
ja ich kann es nicht anders sagen es gab
zahlreiche fresken es gab zahlreiche
reden herr kollege mützenich das hätte
man alles sagen können dass sie das
hundertprozentig unterstützen wir warten
darauf bitte schön machen sie es und ich
will etwas zum thema abschreckung sagen
ein kollege wird sie nicht weil sie sich
da das haben sie heute nicht wiederholt
aber die vergangener zeit schon dazu
eingelassen haben das ist nicht schön
aber abschreckung ist leider notwendig
damit man nicht erst in diese
moralischen abwägungen hineinkommt die
robert habeck jetzt bei der frage der
waffenlieferung hier sehr treffend heute
umschrieben hat das verrückte ist das
perfide ist doch dass die ukraine jetzt
dafür bestraft wird dass sie 1994
nuklear waffen abgegeben hat und diese
rechnung darf doch nicht aufgehen und
deswegen darf man doch nicht herr
kollege nützen möchte ich sagen in aller
freundschaft die wir auch immer den
politischen diskurs miteinander führen
deswegen kann man sich doch nicht
hinstellen und sagen nukleare
abschreckung funktioniert nicht leider
funktioniert sie doch und deswegen
brauchen wir deutschen sie deswegen
braucht die nato auch die nukleare
abschreckung damit wir den russen nicht
ausgeliefert sind und da wird es jetzt
sehr konkret werden und da müssen wir
sie daran und da sind wir mit sicher das
hat der fraktionsvorsitz für meine
fraktion angekündigt da sind wir der
meinung über alles kann man reden auch
über sonderfonds natürlich aber dann
muss es ein gesamtkonzept geben was
insbesondere die bundeswehr betrifft
dass wir auch eingebunden werden einen
blankoscheck der cdu/csu-fraktion den
sie dann irgendwie verwenden wird es
nicht geben sondern wir verlangen
einbezogen zu werden in die diskussion
und wenn wir so gemeinsam handeln meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren so kann
ein möglicher militärischer sieg der
putin vielleicht gelingen könnte wir
hoffen es alle nicht dann soll er und
muss er in jedem fall ein kurs sie
werden dieser mann muss sich
verantworten nicht nur vor dem
russischen volk kolleginnen und kollegen
der ard sondern vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof da gehört er hin
herzlichen dank
die bürgern wadephul war das einer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der cdu
csu fraktion vielleicht haben sie ihnen
um viertel vor elf schon bei uns im
interview gesehen mit anja gruber
zusammen von den grünen rüdiger lucassen
ist ja nächster redner
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher der
spd fraktion er spricht aus bekannten
gründen von der tribüne die kollegen die
atommacht russland hat die ukraine
angegriffen ein militärischer sieg
putins ist wir sehr wahrscheinlich zu
einem enorm hohen preis was kommt dann
ein land doppelt so groß wie deutschland
im guerillakrieg repressionen terror
dauerhafte die stabilisierung an der
ostgrenze der eu dramatische aussichten
viele von ihnen wünschen sich eine
niederlage putins ich auch aber was käme
dann einsicht rückkehr in die
internationale gemeinschaft übergabe der
macht an einen friedlichen nachfolger
unvorstellbar putin ist all in gegangen
verliert er kann er erst recht kann es
erst recht zu einem albtraum aufstand
des russischen volkes aufstand des
militärs machtkampf im staatsapparat
eine niederlage putins ist
unkalkulierbar weil russland atommacht
ist meine damen und herren wir haben
eine historische chance verpasst
europa und wir deutsche haben es nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg nicht geschafft
eine friedensordnung zu bauen die
russland integriert 1990 bekamen wir
dazu eine zweite chance auch die haben
wir nicht genutzt putin hat uns angebote
gemacht wir sind aber nicht darauf
eingegangen wir haben es nicht vermocht
das sicherheitsinteresse der russischen
föderation zu verstehen und zu
akzeptieren
wir haben denen geglaubt die es bewusst
nicht verstehen wollten jetzt ist es
dafür zu spät jetzt haben wir wieder
krieg mitten in europa einen
angriffskrieg der durch nichts zu
entschuldigen ist auch nicht durch die
ignoranz des westens in den letzten 25
jahren
was heißt das für deutschland wir sind
hart auf dem boden der realität
aufgeschlagen die brutale politik der
macht ist zurück und fegt die
gesinnungsethik aus der deutschen
politik deutschland hat keine
alternative die bundesregierung muss nun
auch das steuer in richtung machtpolitik
herumreißen macht heißt auch
militärische fähigkeiten zu besitzen
deutschland hat diese fähigkeit nicht
mehr jeder hier im hause weiß dass die
bundeswehr kann unser land nicht
verteidigen und sie kann deutschlands
verpflichtungen im bündnis nicht
nachkommen was wir jetzt brauchen ist
die größte
rüstungsaufträge das lässt sich nicht in
einem jahr bewerkstelligen auch nicht
mit den tatsächlich erforderlichen 100
milliarden aber die bundesregierung ist
auch dafür verantwortlich das
bewusstsein für eine neue wehrhaftigkeit
in unserem volk zu schärfen meine damen
und herren die wehrpflicht in
deutschland muss reaktiviert werden wann
wenn nicht jetzt wehrhaftigkeit ist der
preis unser freiheitlich danken
vielen dank herr kollege lukas nächste
rednerin ist die kollegin gabriele
heinrich spd fraktion und sie ist eine
der stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren lieber kollege wadephul ich
glaube wir brauchen die schärfe in der
diskussion nicht ich find's super
schwierig jemanden vorzuwerfen was er in
seiner rede nicht gesagt hat weil sie
natürlich eine andere sensibilisierung
an der stelle haben wir werden
miteinander um den haushalt diskutieren
und wir werden dahin kommen dass wir
alle miteinander wollen nämlich die
bundeswehr zu stärken
jetzt kann ich zum thema zurück der
angriff auf die ukraine eine historische
zäsur es wurde heute schon häufig gesagt
dieser angriff hat die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört dieser wahnsinn
diese von pretty präsident putin
vorangetriebene eskalation der von ihm
selbst geschaffenen krise macht
fassungslos und schockiert und wir sind
schockiert aber nicht in schockstarre
der westen ist vorbereitet und er ist
mir geeint denn wir alle stehen in
diesen dramatischen tagen an der seite
der ukraine das streben der ukraine und
ihrer inneren nach demokratie nach
freiheit nach selbstbestimmung ist ein
menschenrecht und das ist nicht vom
wohlwollen eines präsidenten putin
abhängig
wir trauern um die toten die verletzten
die männer frauen und kinder der ukraine
die diesem sinnlosen leid ausgesetzt
sind und die so viel angst haben
die menschen in der ukraine brauchen
jetzt unsere hilfe humanitär durch
aufnahme der flüchtlinge durch druck
gegen das russische regime die politisch
verantwortlichen und diejenigen die
diesen verbrecherischen überfall
ermöglichen auch die militärische
unterstützung der ukraine ist nunmehr
folgerichtig
meine damen und herren deutschland und
seine verbündeten haben lange den weg
der diplomatie gewählt und putin das
gespräch um die zusammenarbeit angeboten
das wohl von vielen seiten auch im
nachhinein als naiv kritisiert aber für
den versuch über gespräch und diplomatie
eskalation zu vermeiden und zu beenden
werden wir uns niemals schämen
auch in der russische präsident dieses
angebot auf brutale weise ausgeschlagen
hat allein er hat es jetzt in der hand
diesen irrweg zu verlassen das töten zu
beenden
meine damen und herren dieser brutale
überfall des aufzugs eines verqueren
welt wird es einer absurden
interpretation der geschichte und eines
imperialismus den wir für überwunden
hielten mit seinem vorgehen und seiner
rhetorik knüpft wladimir putin an die
dunklen zeiten der russischen und
sowjetischen geschichte an sein vorgehen
reiht sich ein in seinen kampf gegen all
diejenigen die eine echte aufarbeitung
der russisch sowjetischen geschichte und
des stalinismus wurden
deshalb hat er die
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
aufgelöst und das war nur einer von so
vielen angriffen auf die lebendige
humanistische erinnerungskultur und die
menschenrechte in russland
es reiht sich ein in immer autoritäre
tendenzen innerhalb russlands und immer
enger werdende freiräume für
menschenrechtsaktivisten und die
zivilgesellschaft und umso mehr
beeindrucken die proteste gegen den
krieg die wir in vielen städten russland
sehen könne der mut dieser oft jungen
menschen gegen autokratie und für den
frieden aufzustehen der kann gar nicht
genug bewundert werden das risiko hafte
zu werden oder sogar zu verschwinden ist
immens gestiegen aber alle mittel der
repression werden nichts nützen die
mittel des krieges und der unterdrückung
die der menschenverachtende aggressor
wladimir putin gewählt hat werden sich
auf dauer nicht durchsetzen davon bin
ich überzeugt vielen dank
vielen dank
gabriele heinrich stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd fraktion und auch
der nächste redner ist stellvertretender
vorsitzender der in die story expansion
und warum das alles im moment so ist das
erzähle ich ihm gleich
sehr geehrter herr präsident kolleginnen
und kollegen seine exzellenz botschafter
meldung dieser krieg ist putins krieg
dieser angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
ist völkerrechtswidrig eine schande und
in keiner weise zu rechtfertigen vor
allem nicht historisch er ist real und
findet in unserer nachbarschaft statt
die zeichen waren da die truppen standen
bereit warum haben wir putin dennoch
unterschätzt weil wir vielleicht unsere
analyse zu sehr auf die vermeintliche
nationalität der akteure gestützt haben
wir die kaltblütigkeit und die
imperialistischen und revisionistischen
großmacht gedanken putins unterschätzt
haben wir vielleicht es auch nicht
wahrhaben wollten dabei ist putins krieg
die fortsetzung der völkerrechtswidrigen
annexion der krim er ist die fortsetzung
der kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen
in der ost ukraine nicht zu vergessen
die verletzung der territorialen
integrität von georgien er ist auf das
schärfste zu verurteilen und eine
sackgasse jedweder auseinandersetzung
putin
putin bringt fürchterliches leid über
die menschen in der ukraine
ihnen gilt unsere uneingeschränkte
solidarität ihnen und den mutigen
russinnen und russen die in diesen
stunden aufbegehren gegen ein
autoritäres und despotisches regime
ihnen die in kenntnis von polizeigewalt
und repressalien in russland trotzdem
für den frieden auf die straßen gehen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser russische angriffskrieg wird auch
massive auswirkungen auf die
sicherheitslage in deutschland und auf
fluchtbewegungen in europa haben hier
auch bereiten wir uns vor und wir werden
denjenigen die schutz bei uns suchen
helfen unsere sicherheitsbehörden haben
sich bereits intensiv auf alle denkbaren
szenarien vorbereitet und
schutzmaßnahmen hochgefahren ich bin
bundesinnenministeriums epheser dankbar
dass sie bereits mit den
landesinnenministern in einem sehr engen
austausch steht und sich auf
europäischer ebene eng mit unseren
verbündeten koordiniert auch jetzt in
diesen stunden ich bin auch unseren
städten und gemeinden dankbar
stellvertretend für viele dem arzberger
bürgermeister ralf paul bittner die
bereits klar zum ausdruck gebracht haben
dass die ukraine den ukraine aufnehmen
wollen die vor dem russischen
angriffskrieg aus ihrem heimatland
fliehen muss kinder
kinder die sich unter tränen von ihren
vätern verabschiedet haben frau ihren
mann vielleicht zum letzten mal in die
arme genommen haben und dieses leid ist
kennt nur eine adresse die verantwortung
dafür liegt im kreml und ich sage es
auch sehr deutlich auch für die trauer
der russischen mutter der jungen söhne
nur im zinksarg nach hause bekommt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
müssen zwar zuerst von flucht und
vertreibung 's bewegung mit innerhalb
der ukraine ausgehen sie haben sich aber
bereits jetzt zu den vergangenen 72
stunden auf die unmittelbaren
nachbarländer wie polen oder die
republik moldau ausgeweitet sie haben
unsere solid solidarität und unsere
humanitäre unterstützung und wir werden
sie massiv unterstützen die
koordinations und unterstützungs
mechanismen der europäischen union
insbesondere für humanitäre hilfe sind
bereits angelaufen
mit ganz konkrete unterstützung sehr
schnell erfolgt und dazu wird
deutschland einen erheblichen beitrag
leisten wir wissen auch dass cyber
angriffe mittlerweile ein häufiges
mittel in konfliktsituationen sind und
wir gehen daher auch für deutsche
stellen von einer erhöhten gefahr durch
cyber-angriffe in der nächsten zeit aus
wir beobachten auch sehr genau dass die
russische propaganda und desinformation
im zuge des ukraine konflikts deutlich
zunimmt bei russia today by telegramm
bei demonstrationen aber auch auf
sogenannten spaziergängen wir müssen uns
auf ein weiter auf zunehmendes ausmaß an
fortwährender russischer desinformation
einstellen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unsere antwort ist und bleibt
freiheit internationale solidarität und
demokratie der platz für
kriegsverbrecher ist und bleibt hingegen
in den haag und nirgendwo sonst vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
natürlich diese einer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der spd
vollzogen und ihnen folgen wird johannes
huber der einzige fraktionslose der
heute hier in dieser debatte spricht
meldet sich von der empore und auch
daraus können sie erkennen dass er bis
zum vergangenen jahr
beziehungsweise zum ende des jahres
mitglied der afg fraktion war
sehr geehrter herr präsident jetzt ist
das mikro an ihre exzellenz liebe
mitbürger der völkerrechtswidrige
angriffskrieg von vladimir putin gegen
die souveräne nation ukraine ist durch
nichts zu rechtfertigen weder durch den
ebenfalls völkerrechtswidrigen angriff
der nato auf jugoslawien noch durch die
nato osterweiterung aus ehemaligen
staaten des warschauer paktes die dem
bündnis aus freier selbstbestimmung
beigetreten sind der gewählte
ukrainische präsident selensky hatte dem
deutschen bundeskanzler und dem
französischen präsidenten in den letzten
wochen fest zugesagt dass er drei
gesetzte im ukrainischen parlament
initiieren wird und das münchner
abkommen vollständig umzusetzen
der diplomatische korridor war also noch
nicht ausgeschöpft das wusste auch putin
er wollte aber die beiden volksrepublik
nicht wieder in die ukraine integrieren
sondern diese friedensordnung mit der
einseitigen anerkennung der
unabhängigkeit der gesamten gebiet
donezk und lohans bewusst aufkündigen
dass es auch keine rechtfertigung für
den überfall auf die gesamte ukraine
sondern für putin das mittel zum zweck
um die ukrainische regierung gewaltsam
und in den bau unter inkaufnahme von
zahlreichen kriegstoten und flüchtlingen
zu stürzen und zur sicherung seiner
eigenen autorität im eigenen land durch
eine gehörige regierung zu ersetzen dass
dieses ziel erreicht ist da dürfen wir
uns nichts vormachen werden die
kampfhandlungen nicht eingestellt und
die truppen später zur sicherung der
künftigen regierung nicht zurückgezogen
auch eine vermittlung von deutschland
und frankreich sieht putin mittlerweile
eher als einmischung das regime putin
muss daher nicht nur mit
personenbezogenen sanktionen gestoppten
isoliert werden sondern auch mit einer
militärischen abschreckung das bedeutet
dass auch deutschland nicht um eine
schnelle und massive ertüchtigung der
bundeswehr sowie einer wehrpflicht auch
zur verteidigung des eigenen landes
herum kommt schließlich droht ihm offen
mit einem flächenbrand in dem er manöver
in moldau und georgien abhält jegliche
ausländische truppen aus den 14 neuen
mitgliedsstaaten der nato vertreiben
will schweden und finnland droht in
bosnien einfluss zur spaltung ausübt und
sich als ehemaliger kgb offizier in der
ddr das geopolitische wieder aufleben
der sowjetunion wünscht herr präsident
ich schließe mit meiner hoffnung die
jetzt bei den unschuldigen russischen
bürgern die mit der politik putins nicht
einverstanden sind sie haben jetzt die
chance dafür zu sorgen dass putin jahr
2024 nicht mehr als präsident
wiedergewählt wird vielen dank
vielen dank der bundestag der musik und
hier wäre die regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers zur aktuellen lage es
kommen jetzt noch fünf redner aus der
spd-fraktion das hat einerseits damit zu
tun dass die spd hier natürlich größte
fraktion ist entsprechend den größten
rede anteil aber sagt die spd-fraktion
es gibt doch so viele unterschiedliche
aspekte dass man die redezeit die der
spd zur verfügung stehen auf jetzt noch
fünf diese rednerin mitgezählt
aufgeteilt hat weil wir gesagt dass
unterschiedliche punkte zu beleuchten
gilt jetzt erst mal sahen ab die
sprecherin für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung der
gesellschaft ausgetragen putin nimmt den
menschen in der ukraine die hoffnung auf
ein leben in frieden rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie auch aus
entwicklungspolitischer perspektive
steht derzeit eine menge auf dem spiel
gemeinsam mit unseren ukrainischen
partnern haben wir in den letzten jahren
fortschritte und veränderungen erzielt
ein maßgebliches projekt im rahmen
dieser zusammenarbeit sind die
partnerschaften zwischen deutschen und
ukrainischen kommunen diese strukturen
erweisen sich in krisenzeiten als eine
effektive verbindung zur ukrainischen
bevölkerung
durch unsere unterstützung haben wir
gemeinsam viel erreicht in den bereichen
bildung energie infrastruktur und in
guter regierungsführung viele
nichtregierungsorganisationen und die
politischen stiftungen haben dazu
beigetragen eine starke demokratie und
zivilgesellschaft in der ukraine
aufzubauen all das wird durch putins
krieg zerstört
meine gedanken sind dabei auch bei den
nationalen mitarbeiter innen der
entwicklungspolitischen organisationen
die diese erfolge erst möglich gemacht
haben ich bin dankbar dass die
organisation mit hochdruck daran
arbeiten die sicherheit ihrer nationalen
mitarbeiterin zu gewährleisten und sie
auch finanziell zu unterstützen
aber auch die breite bevölkerung braucht
nun akut humanitäre unterstützung
hierzu brauchen wir sechs zivilität bei
der bereitstellung der finanziellen
mittel
ich möchte noch auf einen weiteren punkt
aufmerksam machen der russische angriff
kann auf gravierende auswirkungen auf
die länder des globalen südens haben die
ukraine ist ein großer globaler
exporteur von getreide länder die
ägypten libyen geben
[Musik]
importieren große mengen an ukrainischen
weizen ein jetzt zu erwartende
verknappung der lebensmittelversorgung
erhöhte preise können einen dominoeffekt
auslösen
innerstaatliche konflikte kann verstärkt
oder neu angefacht werden und dies alles
vor dem hintergrund der durch corona
ohnehin bedingten wirtschaftlichen
notlage in den ländern des globalen
südens ich vertraue der bundesregierung
auch dies im blick zu haben
mein tiefster respekt geht den menschen
die nun in sankt petersburg und in
moskau trotz der gefahren auf die
straßen gehen um sich mit der ukraine zu
solidarisieren bei dem internationalen
druck der auf putin ein wirkt zeigt sich
am meisten angst hat dieser mann vor
seiner eigenen zivilgesellschaft von
menschen die sich für frieden
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
einsetzen daran sehen wir wie wichtig
eine starke zivilgesellschaft ist ich
bin froh dass der bundeskanzler auch die
notwendigkeit der krisen präventiven
entwicklungspolitik in seiner rede
betont hat das heißt dass 0,7 prozent
oder ziel müssen wir in zukunft
dauerhaft einheiten
verteidigungspolitik geht nur hand in
hand mit entwicklungspolitik denn
entwicklungspolitik ist lebens politik
weiter
vielen dank frau kollegin
und der spd-abgeordneten die werke jetzt
matthias miersch folgen
stellvertretender
fraktion
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben uns in der spd
bundestagsfraktion als fachpolitiker
jetzt aufgeteilt weil einige punkte
sicherlich auch hier näher beleuchtet
werden müssen deswegen will ich sagen
das was olaf scholz heute als
zeitenwende bezeichnet hat betrifft auch
die klima- und energiepolitik dazu in
der gebotenen kürze vier punkte die aus
meiner sicht in den nächsten wochen
monaten und jahren essentiell sein
werden erstens wir müssen die zukünftige
energie und klimapolitik als elementaren
bestandteil von daseinsvorsorge sehen in
diesem haus liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dazu gehört hat
bundeswirtschaftsminister wie sie
zurecht gesagt haben dass die frage von
speicherungen keine thematik von
privatwirtschaftlichen interessen sein
darf sondern ein hoheitlicher aufgaben
gehört liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dazu gehört auch dass wir das thema
energiepreise aus dem blickwinkel der
daseinsvorsorge
betrachten energie muss für wirtschaft
und weite teile dieser bevölkerung
bezahlbar bleiben dafür müssen wir als
staat garantieren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das
zweite energie souveränität geht nur
durch einen weg und das ist der maximale
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und ich
bin ausgesprochen dankbar dass sowohl
der bundeskanzler der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
bundesfinanzminister die ein deutliches
votum abgegeben haben dass der sie male
ausbau unsere aufgabe nummer eins sein
muss liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und herr kollege merz wenn sie dann von
optionen in der energiepolitik reden
dann spüre ich das was ich die letzten
jahre leider in dieser großen koalition
gespürt habe sie haben leider keinen
inneren kompass wenn sie meinen dass
atomkraft weiter eine alternative sein
soll dann sage ich ihnen wir sehen doch
jetzt bei tschernobyl wir sehen bei den
alten reaktoren und die verwundbarkeit
von staaten dass diese technologie nie
eine alternative mehr sein darf liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
von der vierte punkt und er ist der
schwierigste für mich auch als
klimapolitiker
das pariser abkommen gilt weiter
dieser planet
ist zu klein als dass wir es
gegeneinander hinkriegen würden wir
werden alle staaten brauchen wir werden
nur es zu sammeln können und deswegen
hoffe ich dass die diplomatie auch in
dieser frage siegen wird vielen dank für
ihre
aufmärsche fraktion und da haben sie
schon mal einen kleinen vorgeschmack was
an diskussionen kommen wird in den
kommenden wochen und monaten
beispielsweise was die energieversorgung
in deutschland angeht kleiner einschub
je rund um das regierungsviertel
rund um das brandenburger tor mindestens
100.000 menschen auf den beinen die für
den frieden demonstrieren die
veranstalter gehen von sehr vielen mehr
aus die veranstalter haben auch gestern
aber noch gesagt sie hätten diese demo
für 20.000 angemeldet also da schon weit
mehr jetzt nils schmid der
außenpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion
mit unterbringung in
familien teilgenommen mit der stadt
poltawa damals sowjetischen
republik ukraine
damit gehöre einer generation an
die in den letzten 30 jahren versucht
hat die beiden hälften des kontinents
enger zusammenzubringen über
schüleraustausch über wirtschaftliche
zivilgesellschaftliche verflechtung
natürlich auch über viele politische
weichenstellungen wie sie in den letzten
30 jahren über abrüstungsverträge
kooperationsverträge und ähnliches zu
stande gekommen sind eine generation 89
sozusagen die in politik gesellschaft
wirtschaft und medien in den letzten 30
jahren sich da dafür eingesetzt hat dass
wir in ost und west im ganzen kontinent
ein friedliches miteinander eine
gesamteuropäische friedensordnung
aufbauend auf demokratie und freiheit
schaffen und mit dem angriffskrieg von
putin auf die ukraine ist nicht nur eine
zeitenwende eingetreten es ist auch das
ende der hoffnung einer ganzen
generation die nicht 68 nicht von der
nachrüstungsdebatte geprägt ist sondern
eben von derzeit 89 und dem aufbruch hin
zu unseren osteuropäischen partnern und
deshalb ist dieses ereignis dieser
einschnitt in unserer europäischen
geschichte so bitter für viele aus
meiner generation
und wir spüren ganz genau was ist jetzt
auch bedeutet für das praktische
außenpolitische handeln war bisher
bislang dialog und abschreckung die
parole wird es doch wieder mehr
abschreckung und dialog sein
und in der vergangenheit in den letzten
30 jahren hat mir drei elemente wie wir
es geschafft haben den europäischen
kontinent zusammenzubringen gemeinsame
regeln im rahmen der osze der
wirtschaftliche austausch und die
verflechtung und die zivilgesellschaft
all diese drei elemente werden wir auch
noch in zukunft brauchen wir sollten
gemeinsam im deutschen bundestag dafür
kämpfen diese kanäle gerade auch nach
russland aufrechtzuerhalten aber sie
werden deutlich weniger bedeutung haben
sie werden zum teil wenn wir die
wirtschaft und schauen fast keine
bedeutung mehr in zukunft haben können
und deshalb ist es jetzt wichtig nicht
nur heute zu sagen und kurzfristig über
waffenlieferungen oder ähnliches zu
reden sondern müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass wir in einer anderen
politik mischung mit russland in den
nächsten jahren umgehen müssen das eben
abschreckung stärker wird und leider die
elemente die wir die 30 letzten jahre
gepflegt haben weniger bedeutsam werden
das residence deutlich wichtiger wird
und dass wir vor einer daueraufgabe
stehen diese russische herausforderung
die sie putin uns formuliert hat
wirklich zu bestehen und trotzdem und es
war mein appell zum schluss sein lassen
sie uns die wenigen dialog kanäle gerade
auch nach russland in die gesellschaft
hinein nicht aufgeben denn es wird auch
in russland nach putin geben herzlichen
dank
sein kollege schmid der außenpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion und ihm wird
jetzt der verteidigungspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion folgen und das
ist wolfgang hellmich
nächster redner ist der kollege wolfgang
helbig spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr verehrte kolleginnen
kollegen
putin hat mit einem verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört
er gleichzeitig uns alle bedroht im lauf
der letzten jahre haben wir gesehen wie
waffen potenziale aufgebaut worden sind
den hier wirkung bis tief nach europa
hineinreichen und das was in den letzten
tagen im zuge dieses angriffskriege
sehen an drohungen gegenüber ganz europa
muss uns besorgt machen weil im blick
hat er nicht nur die ukraine sohn ehrt
uns alle im blick selbst unsere
werteordnung dick unsere gesellschaften
den blick wert die menschen im blick und
nicht nur im blick sondern im visier und
das ist ein punkt der uns tief besorgt
machen deshalb ist es so wichtig dass
wir gerade in transatlantischen bündnis
der nato unsere fähigkeit noch ausbauen
und stärken in uns gegen diese bedrohung
schützen zu können essentiell für unsere
existenz und es ist essenziell für den
frieden auch in dieser welt den wir
wieder gewinnen wollen denn eines
schafft putin nicht und da sehen wir in
tiflis das sehen wir in der ukraine das
sehen wir in russland das sehen den
vielen europäischen städten den willen
der menschen zum frieden den kann er
nicht brechen das wird er mit charme und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass er in
dieser situation von hier aus von der
demonstration gleich von vielen anderen
stellen auch die botschaft überbringen
dass wir an der seite der menschen
stehen die sich dort den widerstand
befinden und deshalb ist es so richtig
dass in dieser situation auch waffen und
in die ukraine geliefert werden damit
die menschen dort in der lage sind ihr
leben zu verteidigen land zu verteidigen
ihre freiheit und ihr recht zu
verteidigen
und richtig ist er bedanke ich mich
herzlich bei der bundesregierung auf bei
ihrem bundeskanzler in dieser situation
auch deutlich zu machen dass wir unsere
fähigkeiten in der nato stärken und
ausbauen werden dass wir unsere beiträge
liefern werden und dass wir verlässlich
sind unsere soldatinnen soldaten die
gerade in der nato ihrem dienst versehen
die im laufe der letzten tage sich auf
diesen auch auf den weg gemacht haben um
die nato zu stehen dort deutlich zu
machen wir stehen für unsere
bündnispartner so wie wir von unseren
bündnispartnern erwarten dass für uns
ein stehen das werden wir vollumfänglich
erfüllen und der wade pool ich würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt in den
maschinenraum der parlamentarischen
arbeit um das was angekündigt worden ist
das was auf dem tisch liegt auch
entsprechend umzusetzen damit zügig so
soldatinnen soldaten das was ihnen
zugesagt worden ist hier zugesagt worden
ist dann auch zügig auf dem hof auf dem
manga und auch in der werft liegen haben
nicht und erwärmt sondern im hafen und
sie damit umgehen können das halten
dieser stelle man herzlichen dank an
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten die sehr
wohl bewusst wissen welche verantwortung
auf sie zukommt und dann weg erstellen
sie gerade ihren eid nämlich das land
tapfer zu verteidigen auch umsetzen
meinen herzlichen dank dafür bestehenden
ihrer seite wir unterstützen hierbei und
helfen wo wir können vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
herz der regel in dieser debatte ist der
kollege frank schwabe spd fraktion und
farbe ist sprecher für menschenrechte
und humanitäre hilfe und dann haben wir
das spektrum glaube ich wirklich
umfassend
erörtert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen maria
menzel war lisa jasko wolodimir ari 11
und julia lokschina das sind kolleginnen
und kollegen der parlamentarischen
versammlung des europarats und
mitglieder des ukrainischen parlaments
und ich bin in kontinuierlichen kontakt
mit ihm und es ist unbeschreiblich und
unvorstellbar sie sind bewaffnet und sie
versuchen alles zu tun um ihr land und
ihre hauptstadt zu verteidigen und ich
will die gelegenheit nutzen von hier aus
in einem gruß auszurichten aus dem
freien berlin in das freie kirche und
alles wünschen dass kiew auf frei bleibt
normalerweise recht gar nicht hier
sondern auf den weg nach moskau nach
inguschetien und nach da gestern das
schließt sich natürlich jetzt sowieso
ausschließlich aber auch deshalb aus
weil wir russland ausgeschlossen haben
aus dem europarat weil ich wäre
eigentlich in der aufgabe des europarats
dort gewesen wir haben russland
ausgeschlossen ich weiß es gab eine
lange debatte darum das war es aber eine
schnelle entscheidung eine entscheidung
in großer einigkeit und sie war
ohne alternative
ich wollte gerade sagen unumkehrbar ich
hoffe nicht ich hoffe dass russland
eines tages zurückkehren kann in den
europarat aber es wird ein langer und
sehr schwerer weg werden
und ehrlich gesagt es hat auch keinen
sinn mehr gemacht das muss ich leider
hier eingestehen weil russland ja nicht
nur nach außen kriegerischen aggressiv
ist sondern auch im inneren alle
menschenrechte verletzt von demokratie
gerade hat jemand gesagt das muss man
dann demokratisch irgendwie putin
abwählen es gibt kann die demokratie in
russland das ist alles eine farce was
dort entsprechend stattfindet und es ist
eine schande es ist schlimm zu sehen wie
die menschen in der ukraine leiden wie
sie sterben aber es ist doch auch eine
schande dass putin für diesen absurden
krieg seiner eigenen leute verfeuert
wenn man die bilder sieht von jungen
soldaten und soldaten aus russland die
jetzt auf den straßen der ukraine
sterben müssen dann ist es absurd und
dann versündigt sich putin eben auch an
seinem eigenen volk
es ist eben kein kampf gegen großen und
roussel es ist ein kampf um freiheit und
demokratie
und gerechtigkeit
um das freie europa um menschenrechte
und die ukraine steht an der front
dieses krieges für uns alle letztendlich
ich will danken für den antrag den es
heute gibt und er gleich verabschiedet
wird weil er deutlich macht dass wir den
europarat nicht alleinlassen russland
scheidet aus es fehlen gelder im
europarat es wäre ja absurd wenn wir am
ende dafür sorgen würden durch diesen
ausschuss dass der europarat geschwächt
würde im gegenteil es ist das haus der
menschenrechte der demokratie und der
freiheit und das muss jetzt erst recht
gestärkt werden in diesen zeiten
und ich will schließen weil ich viel der
letzte debattenredner heute bin mit
freiheit für die ukraine slava ukraine
vielen dank herr kollege schlage
wir verlegen damit schließlich die
aussprache verbunden mit einem
ausdrücklichen dank an das haus für
diese debatte die dem ernsten lage
wirklich angemessen war
wir trauern mit den opfern in der
ukraine aber ist trauern auch mit down
väter in russland um ihre söhne die in
einem sinnlosen angriffskrieg durch
ihren eigenen präsidenten geopfert
worden sind diesen mit ihren vätern gilt
auch unser mitleid
wenn ich glaube ich spreche im namen des
ganzen hauses denn wir hoffen dass so
sinnloses termine ukraine
schnellstmöglich ein ende findet
liebe kollegen überlegen wir kommen zur
abstimmung über die
entschließungsanträge
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
afg auf drucksache
843 wer stimmt für diesen
entschließungsantrag in diesem
entschließung jahre darum dass sich die
bundesregierung einsetzen soll für einen
waffenstillstand für eine friedensgruppe
und die soll das veto zur
nato-mitgliedschaft erneuern das klingt
keine mehrheit gefunden es gibt einen
weiteren entschließungsantrag der fdp
fordert sie eine allgemeine wehrpflicht
mit mindestens 30.000 wehrpflichtige ja
auch abgelehnt wir sind beim
entschließungsantrag der linken
gefordert mehr diplomatie internationale
abkommen und verträge müssen eingehalten
werden eine waffenruhe
für die soll sich die bundesregierung
einsetzen und überhaupt die ukraine
unterstützen und schließlich der
entschließungsantrag von spd union
grünen und fdp der auf diplomatie
gesetzt auf eine unterstützung der
ukraine auf eine modernisierung der
bundeswehr eine stärkere nato und die
sanktionen müssten je nach weiterer
entwicklung angepasst und werden und da
gibt es natürlich entsprechend der
verteilung auch eine große breite
mehrheit für diesen entschließungsantrag
und damit nähert sich diese sitzung
diese sondersitzung des deutschen
bundestags auf langsam dem ende
entschließungsanträge angenommen die mit
ihren kollegen wir sind damit heute am
schluss unserer tagesordnung ich berufe
die nächste sitzung des deutschen
bundestages ein auf mittwoch den 16 märz
2022 13 uhr die sitzung ist geschlossen
und damit endete eine sitzung des
deutschen bundestages die erstmals an
einem sonntag statt gefunden hat macht
man sich ja auch nicht ganz klar und
denkt na ja wie zwar schon mal gegeben
haben 1 hat es nicht vorher gegeben es
war eine besondere sitzung und ein
besonderer tag manche werden sagen es
war ein historischer tag hier im
deutschen bundestag
wir haben die regierungserklärung gehört
von olaf scholz und die aussprache dazu
der begriff der zeitenwende ist
wiederholt zitiert worden in denen reden
aber er hat auch konsequenzen in den
kommenden wochen und monaten wird sich
die deutsche außen die deutsche
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
insgesamt weitreichend verändern und das
wiederum wird weitreichende folgen für
den bundeshaushalt
nur wenn wir alleine auf das 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr gucken die wollen finanziert
werden die brauchen aber auch eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und im deutschen
bundestag und das bedeutet wiederum
intensive debatten und entscheidungen
und ich glaube dass viele entscheidungen
die auch gestern beispielsweise
getroffen worden sind auf europäischer
ebene etwa oder auch durch die
bundesregierung in ihren auswirkungen
überhaupt noch nicht über geschweige
denn absehbar sind ja das war von einem
besonderen tag während wir dann noch mal
sehen wie der bundeskanzler und der
oppositionsführer friedrich merz sich
nochmal
zumindest grüßen ricarda lang die grüne
vorsitzende uns dass gsk spd-vorsitzende
stehen auch noch beieinander es gibt
weitere zu berichten über diesen
heutigen tag der noch lange nicht zu
ende ist und deswegen verabschieden wir
uns aus dem bundestag und ich gebe
zurück zu stephan kulle in bonn ja danke
schön erhard scherfer nach berlin in den
bundes